and we are here for more junior speeches
championship coverage i'm grand master
robert hess alongside me is the
inimitable grandmaster simon williams
simon it's been a long time since we
we've commentated together but i'm
certainly looking forward to today
yeah certainly robert i mean we were
just trying to work out when the last
time we commentated together was and we
we we couldn't we couldn't figure it out
but um it's going to be a great day
chess today this is a a semi-final i'm
very much looking forward to
oh i am as well and honestly it's been
so long it could be before one of these
partitions was born because when we're
dealing with the jfcc in particular
nihal sarin he is a young superstar from
india hike martyrosian is an absolute
beast in the online servers but he's 20
years old you know he's yeah he's too
old for this at this point and neil
saaren is just a young teenager a
superstar uh both the president and the
future of the world of chess
yeah certainly i mean this this match is
going to be a fantastic match um i've
met nihal a couple of times i sort of
shared a place with him even a couple of
years ago in iceland very very nice kid
i don't know hike so much but their
chess talent is going from strength to
strength and
to call this match i i mean it's going
to be very interesting as we'll see soon
but we're in for a great afternoon here
morning there of chess so it's going to
be fantastic i feel we certainly are and
it is as close to a toss-up you can not
favored available is as well in the
three plus one but then the bullet
favors nihal sarin and simon i often
feel like in these matches if you keep
it close but when you get to the bullet
the side that's better at bullet can
pull through at the end
yeah certainly i mean these matches um
they they often
sort of someone gets a bit of a role
going which can happen and they can get
a little bit of the lead but then the
other person gets a role going a lot of
it i think is just that sort of energy
behind the moves but you're right if it
goes to a close situation going into the
bullet section um anything can happen
because you get a lot of games going on
it's quite random i've seen nihal and
hayek both played bullet obviously
they're both amazing but nihal is so
tricky he's such a tricky little flagger
i've seen him flag so many people before
obviously it's a bit harder to flag at
this time limit because it's one second
extra move but it's uh it's going to be
extremely extremely close the match it
certainly will and hike was so
impressive in his win over parham
maxoudlu in the quarterfinals and parham
obviously no slouch both to the broader
world of chess and the online chess
community in particular that's a former
world junior champion somebody who's
always rated towards the top of the
leaderboard so hike much rosen proves
that he can you know fight with the best
them here and he is the slight favorite
today i was a bit surprised by that
because nihal is the top seed but that's
just how well ike martirosian has played
thus far
yes i am i mean again it could go either
way i mean if i was going to pick
someone it's like it really is so hard
uh to say i think it's who's going to be
best on the day
um i i can't really pick one person to
win it i was very impressed i wanted to
say the way hike played in his last
match that was really clever he kept
fighting even in positions where he was
much behind really struggling he he was
so resourceful and you have to have that
resourcefulness but
nihal has that same level of
resourcefulness which is shown time and
time again um
if i'm looking at results at title
tuesday events i know they got the stats
there but i'm just doing this without
any stats given to me but i know that
hike is always always up there at the
top neil nihal has been but hike has
been consistently there
i don't know it's going to be
interesting be good to see what people
think in the chat um of who's going to
win and yeah what do you think robert
you
are you gonna put your neck on the line
here oh my gosh it's so tough because
nihal was
struggling out of the gate and we
actually have liftoff right now but he
was struggling out of the gates against
anton smirnov and he pulled through in
the end because of the bullet so he kept
it close enough went to the bullet and
then took that match but hayek
martyrossen is a super tough player as
you see just by their ratings they're
about even 30 31 for hike 30 18 for
nihal sorry and that can change with
every single game and it will and i
guess simon now the chess is here i'm
not gonna put my neck on the line
because i just did a really roundabout
way of talking about other things uh i'm
gonna all right i'll go nihal saarin's
slight favorite that's where i'm going
with this okay i'm gonna have to go the
other way robert just to be different so
i'm gonna i'm gonna go hike slight
favorite but i do know me how better so
i you know he was a very nice you know
guy to analyze with so i kind of like to
see me how win i know we're not supposed
to be biased got nothing against hike
it's just that when you know someone
slightly better you kind of you're kind
of rooting for them but
starting off with quite a sort of
solidish um semi slave here robert
yeah you know not uh
not the most exciting in the early
stages but there's a lot of potential in
such a position because this bishop on
c8 for black you have to figure out am i
playing b6 and then bring this bishop
out to say b7 or a6 and is black playing
for c5 that's sort of the main question
i have and then from white's perspective
over here oh what is your actual plan
here are you going to push e4 at some
moment are you just going to move your
bishop out in castle i'm sorry what do
you think is going to happen in this one
i'm what i think knee how's starting you
know nice and nice solid structure here
because the other option which i think
maybe even gary kasparov played a couple
of times was castling queen side for
white that would have le that would have
led to a very exciting sort of battle in
both areas but i think he's just
deciding maybe after last match right
let's just get into the game and you can
see this now by the trade on d5 he's
simplifying the position
not really going for a big advantage but
just trying to get some small nibble
from the position here um but black is
very solid here as well
and he plays a6 i was about to mention
that the one major difference is that
there's a knight on c3 compared to a
knight on d7 the knight on d7 a
superfluous knight because there's a
knight in f6 stopping its progress to
march forward and the pawn on d4 pawn
three squares from away from the knight
always dominates that knight your knight
can't get forward so that is a slightly
better piece placement for white but
nothing all that major especially after
a6 saying hey your knight's not getting
to b5 and you're not getting to the c7
square
yes i mean this kind of exchange has
been played before but black has
certainly got the right idea here
transferring that knight towards the
queen side just getting rid of the worst
place piece and maybe even as a knight
e4 later on in the game to try and use
the bishop on b7 and get a bit of
activity
a very solid start here white on the
other hand has the open c file where he
has potential to come into c7 at some
point with a queen and uh you know put
push push over there but it's it's
looking fairly even they're sort of you
know like two boxes they're kind of not
swinging they're not swinging too fast
at the moment they're just eyeing up
each other at this uh at this stage of
the game certainly and one now major
difference of the pawn b5 is if white
can get a knight to c5 because you've
that's a potential outpost you don't
have a pawn that can kick a knight from
that square whereas if this knight goes
b6 knight c4 why can you just play b3
and say hey shoot you you look good
there for the moment but you're not
lasting very long
yes and black now going for exchanges
which is a typical way to try and
simplify the position more and i mean if
anyone's better here i'd say white is
slightly better because of the position
of those light square bishops as well uh
white has a better sort of diagonal even
though it's not necessarily doing too
much maybe even white can try some i
can't see at the moment but i was
thinking a4 at some point but it's
there's no problems of black here at the
moment how i mean the two moves i'd say
they have to watch out for are these
knight jumps maybe knight e4 95 that
could change the sort of dynamics of the
position and you know you always want to
consider that if you're going to try and
push for a win especially in such a
symmetrical uh position as this
yeah and another thing i'll notice this
rook an f8 would rather be an a8 because
then you could trade on c1 and bring a
second rook to the c file whereas white
can take on c8 and then replace the rook
with a history he actually does just
that so a slight lead in terms of you
know who's getting into the action first
but will that be consequential i don't
really see how you take advantage of the
fact that you're already on the c file
no and now now black is ready to play
this rook c8 move and exchange off that
sort of one advantage that white kind of
had there the open c file
white making exchanges on g3 i mean the
only thing i can sort of see maybe white
trying to do is an a4 move later on to
try and probe those pawns but
even that move seems a long way off um
so i don't know i mean maybe if rook c8
is played can he exchange it go knight
e5 that's something worth considering
but it's risky okay blacks black's
played it very solidly here maybe queen
d6 at some stage as well
yeah just trading everything off simon
but i i do think that there's more life
left in the position than i would
initially care to admit because this
bishop on d3 is so much better than the
bishop on b7 you mentioned this 94 idea
in end games in particular i'll just
take your knight on e4 and play knight
against a bishop that doesn't attack
anything so there is potential for black
to initiate a wrong trade
yes and um i i suppose the other thing
as you mentioned robert is if white can
ever get a knight into c5 this is a
square later on that knight can maybe
travel you know to d2 b3 or something
like this you your picture on the board
and you know black will struggle to
exchange that whilst white can stop
blacks knights coming in maybe that b5
pawn is a little bit overextended it's
it's not much at all at the moment um
but if i was white i certainly want to
play this position on um for as long as
i could just to see if i can get
anything out of it
i'm with you and actually i might even
consider keeping the queens on the board
queen d2 say wait a sec that's c5 square
that we keep talking about maybe i can
get there going knight to b3 next
especially now yeah yeah
king on d6 queen d2 i mean come on i
need to get to b4 with check what's your
king doing out here yeah queen d2 looks
like a really strong move here because
he's played it he's played it i mean
black's
banking on the queen exchange now but
with the queen coming to b4 and the
knight coming to b3 this can actually be
quite a serious advantage brewing here
with those that knight swinging in to
one of those great squares on a5 and c5
and the black king probably wants to
walk its way back now
you know put it back on g8 it is sort of
done this walk to walk to death there i
mean okay it's not going to get
checkmated but it can always come across
annoying checks uh in this position here
which will gain white tactical
opportunities for sure and you know you
want to look at base pawns g7 f7 if the
king goes to b8 and this queen does get
to b4 into squad e7 you have to watch
out that you won't just lose some of
your pawns on the king side as well as
the fact that this knight is coming to
b3 okay and if you go knight to b6
you're welcoming my knight into b3 or
this knight into e5 where i attack f7
right away so i'm just starting to look
really really good for nihal definitely
i mean now that knight has the
opportunity to come into e5 maybe here
um
before black can go knight on f to d7 or
something and okay the check makes a lot
of sense
and now the king okay well he's he's
building up the forces here yeah queen
and knight this is actually all of a
sudden changed massively for black black
should have played queen takes c1 got
rid of those queens before venturing the
king up to the board like this
yeah i mean right now there might even
be bishop takes b5 check because once i
take back i check and hit your knight on
a4 but you have to calculate you don't
want to you know risk too much here as
white by stacking a piece but i get the
feeling that this just works bishop b5
check takes queen takes you have to play
bishop c6 in order to defend your knight
and then there's like 95 check and
maybe yeah and he's got time to think
about such a move as well because this
timeline does give you that that benefit
here and something like this could just
be winning simple as that um
with the black king again you can see it
just in this diabolical situation here i
mean can you hold on i mean king d6 just
doesn't look like it should hold on um i
think it's over because you have to
bring the king and i just take the
bishop and yeah was your night yeah yeah
yeah so is he gonna find it let's see
would he find bishop b5 because
if he does find this move
which he's thinking about he's got time
he this is very clever of me how he's
using his time when he's spotted a
tactic he wants to make sure the tactic
is working you can see he's calculating
it i really expect he's gonna find this
bishop takes b5 move this the this this
this i mean
he's gonna find it isn't he robert he
must i mean he can be thinking about 95
check and then the consequence of king
ea queen d6 something like that but yeah
he's played it he's played it and this
could just be game over already actually
a very smooth game here from niha i mean
that's very positive because he's never
been worse and he's okay this big
mistake of black moving the king that's
assuming he's going to win this one is
is a nice way to start without ever
being in trouble at all yeah it's sort
of funny simon that this game was
decided by the fact that height didn't
trade queens and even if he had traded
queens we were talking about how white
has a slight pull because of the
superior minor pieces in particular this
bishop on b7 is very bad behind upon d5
and so now hike is down a couple of
pawns he's going to try to somehow
survive this but it's not looking very
likely
no maybe white can sort of give a check
and bring the queen back somewhere
sensible like to c3 worst case scenario
d2
um there might be a better way of
playing this of course um
black's best bet is certainly to throw
the queen in trying to get the knight to
e4 and to complicate he's not risking
anything now by by playing such a plan
but um i'm assuming that white can cover
all these squares uh with careful play
must be a way i'm not maybe there's
queen b5 check bishop c6 and queen c5 so
forcing the bishops
he goes he's going this way he's going
for a tactical finish ah queen before
where like where's the where is the
finish that's always the annoying thing
at least i find silence i know i'm up to
pawns i should be winning yeah where is
the actual win yeah we saw this actually
a lot in in the last match with uh hike
and parham was getting these kind of
positions but he wasn't actually
finishing him off and it's that
finishing touch which is so important
and hike was so resilient even in these
losing positions i expect that knee how
will simply wings he's got his queen c1
move uh here but um
going for his best option and again this
this seems sensible to at least try
keeping the queens on the board to
complicate the situation as much as you
possibly can very clever check there
that you pointed out robert putting that
bishop on c6 where it's now going to be
a target to attack yet actually this is
another miss by nihal he could have
forced the queens off by instead of
playing his queen back to uh d2 look at
the time as well i mean this is this is
a position where
okay of course you're winning but you
know
suddenly there's a threat yeah suddenly
you could get mated if you're not
careful
yeah 94 is maybe a tricky mcqueen h1
check forcing a block on the f1 square
but i mean white has to push these pawns
at some point not so easy to accomplish
i mean white is doing well but the time
situation now it is going to complicate
this matter a lot
he just if he gets the queens off he's
laughing if he gets the queens off he's
laughing but he's got to work away or
just maybe push the pawns that's it
queen five he wants to get his queen in
this oh
just
stopping that move
yeah all these squares are covered yeah
somehow and if he's just pushing his
apartment like can you just keep going
he won't he wants the queen why not and
push it again he's done it yes a6 oh
nice fine hits the bishop and now
queen b5 check and go into yeah get into
the position here
he's gotta be a little bit careful
because the black king's very safe here
and all of a sudden white's king's very
open is this so clear even no i i mean
it's it's seems to be
i don't know i mean it just seems like
that could you have to watch out for
perpetual say queen is coming in right
can you one does queen e3 oh i don't
know about this black's got at least a
draw right right queen d1 queen e2 and
the kings are trying to run to h3 but it
doesn't get too far yeah and you can see
nihal on the uh on the camera is oh can
can black even get the knight in and try
to win this why not like you know
83 and then you want something like that
what is he's going
oh he took the pawn hanging man what
happened there that wasn't a check no
but i guess there's queen h1 uh was the
threat this is getting confusing i mean
they're just moving so quickly and oh
here comes the knight
okay so he's risking it he's he's
allowing white to queen and i think he
might be he might be
very close to mating nihal with knight
f2
is that right yeah now if you play the
wrong knight move apparently i see
the ball swung
where's the draw oh queen takes g7 okay
c4 what a move giving the king the g3
square oh
this is tense this is tense stuff now
whoa and somehow this is just zeros i
see the bar over there zeros of course
well it's still a bit of play here yeah
i mean it should it should of course be
a draw but um queen g7 um
queen take pawn queen f4 why can't you
go queen is that working i don't know if
that was working i was trying to figure
that out really quickly
too much queen f6 this is also working
king g3
and then king f4 after you take on b3
and you get me this has been messy
robert this this game has been
incredibly messy it's going backwards
and forwards and even here with three
seconds each left i mean obviously white
is pushing for the win but can black
hold this one he's turned down the draw
earlier on um
it's been a turnaround this one every
move pretty much this has been
absolutely wild and i mean nihal was
winning earlier hayek was turning this
round probably had a checkmating net
missed it and then actually nihal missed
a win with after that queen took on b3
and i think we'll see a draw it's my
best guess okay but the king can now
come yeah say 27
ah okay yeah oh no
you missed it yeah because now the king
is really good
key e5 no checks white's making serious
progress here serious progress
this should be winning now before
queenie six check was uh also tempting
but okay he's played it now
he can he could have his key to f6 there
yes key of six there's no check yeah and
he's done it and now he's threatening
mate in two so this is the only move
queen d8 27 got it this is over this is
over knee house knee has somehow won
that one what a relief that was that was
a crazy start
and the game lasted 15 minutes for a you
know five plus one game so you know it
went a long time um i don't even know
they let's go back very quickly just to
see those moments where it felt like
hike was the one who was taking
advantage of some mistakes when he
brought his uh knight to um
f2 but i don't even know where that was
it's like yeah all the way back here
maybe maybe it was knight e1 that was uh
better i i i wasn't sure like this
knight 91 looks good because you've got
those dual threats you've got queen g2
so g4 is is ruled out in the position oh
but this queen's xd5 there i mean the
queen stop all the checks all right wow
wow whatever
it is it is yeah i guess somehow uh
barely holding on and then towards the
end of the game it was just uh
an absolute mess but we're gonna go back
live to this game you know these players
they're under the pressure trying to
figure out all these tactics with no
time on their clock it's really
difficult yeah
i say i mean that that first game i i
think it was a bit of a nervous game you
know both these guys obviously have a
lot of respect for each other they must
do and uh yeah there was a lot of nerve
showing there but i think they're gonna
they're gonna relax down into their
proper play sort of soon they must be
able to do that this position
i suppose is pretty standard robert
white's trying to rely on the two
bishops here and his dance square bishop
to get some advantage yeah that's
clearly the gold bishop b2 and say hey i
have the long diagonal and the one thing
i don't like about white's position is
the pawn structure on the queen side
here the a4 b3 structure this bishop on
c4 is holding everything together but if
i play bishop e6 and trade off your the
bishops i feel like there's some
weaknesses that you'll have to deal with
for a long time
yes it's going to be a trade-off with
those that pawn on b3 probably and
white's dark square bishop if i can try
to get that bishop working somehow um
then you know he's going to give him
active play but you're right the the
pawn the pawn kind of wants to be back
on a2 in some ways but then you allow b5
uh in the position so it's it's it's a
little bit tricky to get your perfect
setup as white with your pawns on the on
the queen side here that's true yeah
i mean bishop e6 comes to mind bishop f5
you want to keep the bishops on for some
reason i would trade i always feel like
when my opponent has the two bishops
removing one of them you know swapping
it off is beneficial for me because then
i only have to worry about one diagonal
and not both
yeah i suppose you could consider knight
a5 but actually that knight might be
worth keeping
in some ways maybe the knight is better
than your bishop so well okay knee how's
long now gone for the most i'd say
aggressive move um he's keeping the
bishops on but that pin is a little bit
annoying for hike as well
yeah so you just drop back bishop to h5
and keep it going he says rook d8 okay
it makes sense and he can always take on
f3
and then play knight to e5 if he wants
to get the bishop off the board but
there's something
about this situation uh simon it feels
like neil doesn't want to actually take
this bishop
yeah right i guess after b takes c4 then
it could be black who gets a little bit
of pressure on the b7 pawn or something
um
in this position so all he has done it
so i mean queen takes is
possible but i like this b takes
um
with not root b1 now but at some point
in the future possibly right well big
issue is you can't play bishop b2
because the 52 happens so maybe white's
just a little bit slow at the moment
it does seem that way because how do you
get your bishop in the game rook d2 is
coming and um black has the d file which
is very important in such positions if
black can just go rook d7 rook d8
some simple moves maybe put the rook on
g6 with d6 if you really want to try
something uh a little bit scary it's uh
it seems it seems pretty pretty
comfortable for black
yeah i actually like this rook d6 move
it felt a little bit more flexible and
you could also put your queen on d7 so
sandwich uh with the queen there on the
d file but he plays rook d7 which was
your first uh suggestion so i guess he
just went for the calmer approach but i
did like rook d6 some i think it gave
you more flexibility yeah i guess the
advantage you're putting on d7 you cover
the the be the b7 pawn maybe your
queen's a little bit more active yeah in
some variations but with the rook coming
to d8 and white's still not able to well
you can go bishop b2 but do you really
want to allow the rook into d2 and this
moves a bit ugly f3 i mean uh i see we
have ben feingold in the chat and i know
he's a big fan of f3 and f6 news i don't
know i don't know what he thinks of f3
here i mean with a pawn on h2 it's much
better but it seems a little bit ugly
because you give this g3 square some
dark squares maybe it has to be played
but it's not really what you want to
play you're sort of just your pawns are
a little bit weak now i feel completely
agreed and also black's moves feel easy
knight g3 is just the first move it's
not really requiring much thought rook
to d8 if you attack my knight i can
always drop it back to h5 if need be i
can bring my queen into h4 to reinforce
the knight and also put an eye on the c4
pawn so i just feel like it's more i
mean knight f5 now as possible right the
e pawn is pinned to the right and then
bring my knight into d4
very nice yeah and he's played it i mean
he's uh both these players amazing
positional players i mean uh they they
know where to put their pieces and the
knight on d4 is now gonna dominate that
bishop and probably white's gonna have
to try to exchange that knight off for
his bishop otherwise there's no way you
can get rid of it so all the advantages
seem to be on black side at the moment
and uh knee how playing very well in
this game
yeah he's getting off to a good start in
the early stages of both games and right
now he plays look at this what a calm
move that's very calm could put my
knight on d4 but why don't i just make
sure my king has some love so i don't
get checkmated on the back rank in the
future i like that that's just that's
class
a petrosian like move
the the old one yeah so
um h6 just giving king a little bit of
safety and and not rushing the position
and now he has to move the knight here
so
all right um he played the british
bishop to e3 but that's the problem and
you are sort of highlighting this is
white's best opportunity with the bishop
is to take the knight and you know you
take the knight you give over the
default or you even allow past pawn
straight away with the pawn replacing
the knight there so
white's prospects don't look very good
and now i'm wondering if black should
play f5 to open up new avenues of attack
yeah f5 is a nice move just to try and
uh increase the pressure somehow um i
mean white's a little bit tied down i
mean white would like to maybe try
doubling on the b file because the one
target the one only target i can see is
this this pawn on b7 but doubling it
it's going to take a bit of time and
your rooks well you're leaving c4 and
pre so i don't even know if you can do
that that kind of idea here
um but how does black improve probably
this f5 idea is correct
yeah and i think important is even
behind this knight is the d2 square so
like let's say i play f5 and you take i
can even take with my knight because
bishop takes c5 is meant by rook d2 and
i'm getting a
pretty nice initiative there so just
may not be so easy for
white to figure out the consequences but
i actually like the way nihal's doing
this is he's saying you guys keep
suggesting moves that are a little more
ambitious i'm going to sit on the
position and ask hike what is your plan
because i don't really see one from
white's perspective here yes i know
obviously now f5 is is much stronger
because white can't even take the pawn
on f5 because the bishop on e3 and i
think this is a very mature way of
playing actually he's just basically
saying
okay i i don't need to play f5 or break
until maybe i'll get a better
opportunity and it's it's it's a good
way to play this way
that's why white's played this rook to
c3 to defend that bishop again against
f5 the queen again he's just probing
here roberts probing those weaknesses
yeah i'm impressed there is something
said that there are players who you know
are too solid they don't go and when the
time is right they don't strike but
right now i like what he's doing as you
pointed out the a4 pawn is under attack
he always has this idea of f5 if he
wants to go for it and he can just swing
his rook back to d7 anymore okay queen
e6 so
is he just saying hey let's repeat once
the old russian school technique yeah he
did this in the last game a couple of
times when when he was clearly doing
very well he repeated the position once
and uh
it's
well it's making it it's quite clever
idea because you know you're gaining a
little bit of time you can think in your
opponent's time and if you're
controlling the position then
you know that if your opponent tries to
do something a little bit different
you're just going to gain some kind of
edge so would he come now back to c6 he
has done
and after rook a3 he's going to have to
try he's going to have to break at some
point i feel though
otherwise how is he going to make
progress here
well maybe he doesn't realize that he is
the better oh and it's hayek who plays
on with queen a2 and we do have the
benefit i'm not i tried not to look at
it but of course i see the evaluation
bar off to the side i don't have the
moves associated with it but you know we
have
descent so we know that black is better
here maybe he doesn't feel like his
position is better but he must right
this just looks good for black
yes yeah i mean he's he's got a he's got
to do that next step though so he's got
the knights he's got the open file kind
of kind of and what's the next plan um
so everything looks good and whenever he
plays the next plan maybe the position's
not going to look as good you know
because he's going to have to change it
and sometimes you don't want to give up
that beautiful looking positions but but
you have to to make progress so he's
still waiting but he has to he has to
break somehow otherwise it will just be
a draw maybe he's gonna maybe he's gonna
go knight e6 and
you know say well okay you know i don't
need to keep my knight there let's take
the default try to get my pieces around
the back my knight can come back to
d4 later on um this is another way of
black playing yeah i'm with you and i
actually like that you know you use the
word probing and that's exactly what
he's been doing he's just making white's
life as difficult as possible with every
move no forcing sequences but just
saying hey what's your response can be
are you just going to repeat the
position and the answer has been no thus
far hike is not doing that and now the
pawn's in a5 so that's both a strength
and a weakness it's good because it
gives you a plant on b6 to w rooks but
it's bad because hey maybe that pawn
just is more vulnerable to attack
and he's done this knight e6 because his
rook you know the other way apart from
playing f5 to try and do something in
this position for black is to use those
rooks and with the rook coming to d3 and
maybe a queen coming to g3 white has to
be very careful the knight can also flip
into f4
in some situations if if white ever
plays bishop f2 that that black knight
could started a direct assault against
the white king um
so i'm expecting something like rook d3
and i like this very very patient play
from black and we often see this i think
one mistake a lot of players make is
when they have a good position they do
want to force the game they want to
force the pace but actually it's much
better to wait for your opponent to make
a mistake even because they're in an
uncomfortable situation as soon as you
force the pace
it makes their decisions a lot easier to
make and uh okay so he's got knight f4
straight away robert yeah he's saying
just like earlier i don't mind trading
off my knight for your bishop and rook
to b1 hayek is just not reacting he's
just shuffling away but rook to d3 looks
right he does it take please take me on
f4 i need to get to the d2 square that's
black's essential goal yeah and you
can't move your rook off the back right
because they wouldn't rook d1 check ooh
the e4 square is now week two okay well
he's he's the the tempo's changed robert
here suddenly white's like right okay
we're down short time i'm gonna i'm
gonna push and pray
oh he's blunted he's simply blunted
right mm-hmm
that's just this okay it was a tough
position but knee how's patient really
really paying off there and you can see
hike on the camera there looking quite
surprised and well i mean he needs an
absolute miracle now being a whole piece
down
yeah he would just lean back in his
chair or his couch rather it was just
like oh yeah what did i do
that's the end of that one yeah
brilliant start for nihal brilliant
start for the a very actually nihal has
been sort of dominating both games
robert as in he's never well okay he got
a bit messy in the first game but
positionally he's at the moment proving
to be the better player
yeah i would say for about what 90 95
percent of the action we've seen this
far neal's had the advantage it may have
been slight in
the first game but he's been the one
that's pressing controlling the shots as
you were
saying simon so i'm with you i think
that neil has had the better start and
it's a big improvement over his
quarterfinal match against anton smirnov
where out of the gate smirnov was up
something like five and a half two and a
half something to that effect so it's a
very different nihil that we're seeing
today
yes he's playing very well um and hike
really needs to start picking up the
pace because you don't want to be down
by a massive amount at the end of one of
these segments and the other thing is as
soon as you start losing a roll of games
you're more likely to lose after that
because you get this negative thinking
you're getting the negative oh what's
going wrong you might try to force
things you might you might just lose the
plot a little bit so it's horrible when
you get on this role this is the role i
may mention the start of the match
you've got to break out of that somehow
um otherwise it can you can suddenly
just keep losing you know even if you're
not playing that badly your opponent's
confidence also uh becomes greater at
the same time
uh
solid structure as such though here
yeah um i i will add the problem for
when you face nihal sauron is that some
of these players are not quite as good
at bullets so even if you have a several
game deficit and you're the better
bullet player you can make up your
ground but not against neal because he's
the highest rated ball player on the
entire site if i'm not mistaken and plus
good luck to you but in this game simon
i mean i like white's position again i
think that you know you play e4 you just
have this moroxy bind type of situation
with these pawns on c4 and e4 no you're
not getting d5 anytime soon wow he
pushes that pawn to e5 yeah this is a
very aggressive move and uh this this is
this is actually a very i mean i've seen
actually sarawan use this kind of
strategy before um black has to be very
careful if he castles because the knight
g5 is sort of a trick you know just just
hanging in the air uh but okay knight
takes d4 this d6 square is what white's
really aiming for if he can get a knight
cemented into d6
then black will be facing a lot of
problems and he can now do that in two
different ways maybe black has to play
f6 and
try to break like that but it's um
it's looking slightly better for nihal
yet again here yeah and this pawn on d7
is a target and the pawn e5 sort of
dominates that pawn you can play d6 but
then you need to watch out for queen e4
hitting this rook on a8 and even if you
don't win that rook controlling all the
light squares is very important so the
knight on h6 is out of play a very
clever sequence by nihal to get that
knight there and if you're playing like
yasser sarawan then hey you're probably
playing pretty damn well
yeah yeah little little yasser can we
call him uh
will we see him grab some pawns and
i kind of like this f6 movie
you know even if it doesn't work because
if you're
if you're sort of a little bit worse in
these positions i mean we've seen that
hike has kind of suffered by
not going active and at least he's
trying to break out of this grip somehow
and create some play on the f-file
backfire he could backfire of course
are you sure that
you don't like it just because ben
feingold hates that move
well
there's other options isn't there as
you know
i mean uh we even saw magnus do souped
up f6 think we on move one the other day
you know he it's uh but uh i mean it's
it seems to be okay here with the f5
opening but yeah it does give black it's
some benefits here as you said the f
file opens you also free up your d-pawn
that if you could take on e5 your d-bond
go to d6 for example but right now it's
an important moment for nihal he's
sitting and thinking can i just leave
the pawn there i'll play with a to d1
should i take on f6 and be the side who
flinches first should i play rook f to
e1 to reinforce a capture on the e5
square all of those moves look good to
me but i'm not sure which one is best
and he does take on f6 okay so he's
taken here just to relieve the pressure
and
again he's he's playing he's playing
very solid nihil very solid chess i mean
he's he's not taking any risks he's he's
actually of course he's a very good
tactician but he he's kind of uh saying
okay well i i i've outplayed you a
little bit in the last two games i'm
going to put my pieces on these good
squares and this might be a case robert
where the central pawns central pawns
are supposed to be better than wing
pawns and you can see that black has two
central pawns but you know that's not
always the case and sometimes when
they're on open lines where white can
just place his works to oppose them they
can be more weaknesses than strengths
especially if they're not mobile and and
those pawns are not really mobile you
can never really push them too far
without them becoming even weaker so
it's still an advantage for white that's
for sure and uncomfortable for black to
get his remaining knight out as well
totally with you and you're absolutely
right that in the earlier stages of the
game having the pawns and center should
be good because you're restricting your
opponent's pieces what your pieces want
to be in the center but here that's not
the case any pawn move leaves a huge
hole e5 oh give me that d5 square right
i'll just go knight b5 i can bring my
knight into the d5 square if you play d6
you already drop a pawn but even if you
are not dropping that pawn the c6 square
is also becoming
under white's control so you just don't
have the pawn moves that you would like
and those pawns are going to be victim
to attack in the very near future so a6
i mean that's just kind of a move is he
playing rook a7 next
maybe he's going to try b5
it can he play b5 i mean
he's gone brook a7 so he wants to put it
on c7 this is
this is and then maybe he wants to go
knight c6 so he can try to take with a
rook but it's uncomfortable for black
this is very uncomfortable it's a slow
approach where even if you get like
let's say i give you those two free
moves you go rook c7 knight six all at
once then what i take you on c6 you
still have to take with your pawn
because the rook is needed to defend the
d7 square so knight c6 i just take and
you'd have to take with the pawn you
lose e6 anyway oh this is just no fun i
mean it's i mean the way knee how is
playing as well i mean okay he's kind of
making hike i'm not going to say look
bad but look bad a little bit but he's
and he's not bad he's a fantastic player
he's over three thousand but nihal is
just keeping control and he's doing the
same strategy now as he did in the last
game where when he has that little bit
of control when black can't move his
knight he's not rushing if he can
improve his position a little bit he
will he's getting ready to double his
rooks and he's just being very patient
in the position it's a really clever
clever strategy he's using so far and i
think it's a great one and actually hike
tends to have a pretty similar style
it's like a binding style where you
limit your opponent's
possibilities in the sense that most
moves are you have some downside to them
here like rook c5 is played where's that
rook going can't go to f5 to join the
queen so it just it moved on out but
what next for me i'm thinking do i play
a4 do i maybe go knight h2 knight g4 at
some point just uh does that really
improve the location mine i'm not sure
but i can do what i want because i don't
really see what blacks maybe not h2 is
bad because e5 happens i might have
played my favorite move here i was going
to say h4 i was going to say yeah
i mean again i like this move because
you're just slowly improving it it might
not seem like you're doing much but if
you if you're if you can make sure that
your opponent can't improve their
position you you know you force the
weakness here i i would say the two
moves h4 h6 have helped white
potentially g6 is now a whole for for a
white piece and it's showing this
extreme patience
um and again a lot of people watching
the show
you know one thing i would say about you
know lower rated players that they can
improve on the most is uh looking at
your opponent's ideas and when you
realize that they're actually struggling
to find a plan you'll realize that you
don't have to force something you can
play these like moves and sort of say
right i'm waiting for my opponent to to
do something dodgy while i'm improving
so this is this is really really patient
play and nice play it certainly is and
it's funny because uh nihal is playing
like both of us i said a4 you said h4
and he said why not both that's how much
time he has in this position
he does and and king h8 kind of shows
that black can't do much i mean i don't
think he's ever going to try rook g8 and
g5 that seems i mean
can he play it maybe but you know this
is the kind of thing i was talking about
that you're kind of tempting your
opponent into just making these kind of
rash moves by by showing extreme
patience but uh is he gonna go g5 what
do you reckon will he will he punt it
uh i think that just it makes your
position closer to losing than you know
anything beneficial but
what else can he do i mean what really
what else can you do here yeah
is he just gonna go king g8 king h8 and
say right me how it's up to you you
can't just wait here and torture me
forever um you've got to try to do
something maybe that's maybe that's what
he's going to do he's decided he can't
do anything else because it will make
his position worse so he's going to he's
going to bide his time it's really not
fun playing like that though so it's not
fun but it actually might be objectively
the best idea like what does rook effort
is he what did that move
i i again i i i don't know i'll be
honest okay so now now now black has
actually made a decision
so
um
with knight e5
and
this
okay so this decision
this decision has it helped black or is
it help white i mean to me it still it
still seems like black is uh okay so
he's trying to now get his some freedom
right right
and knight f3 there's rook f5 watch out
that's a big problem down the f1 because
the rook and queen are perfect you just
want one more attacker in there so don't
play knight f3
can you play f4 is that too much i mean
for if it works therefore it's
definitely a good move because uh oh
he's got okay so he's got knight of
three is he gonna repeat the position
like knight d okay he's doing that he's
doing the tactic again he's he's just
he's just squeezing i squeeze you i
squeeze you
[Laughter]
but he he's after rook f5 okay is he
black can't really be thinking he should
play for a win here i mean that'd be
crazy he's got to go rook f5 yeah he's
gonna go back but now is this a draw
it's a draw yeah he's a draw i was going
to say that that that was very
that like that was very strange because
nihal okay maybe nihal didn't realize
that his position was that good there
yeah i actually just looked at their
faces and he didn't really seem upset by
the draw so
even if he was much better there and we
thought that he should play on he didn't
seem to be okay
okay so he's still got the lead two and
a half to half so it's still going knee
how's way and one thing i i think a good
comment in the chat and i'm just keeping
an eye on uh twitch.tv
slash chess com events um for any chat
that's going on and uh i think it was
made by
steph594 and he was basically saying
that smirnoff's uh actually that's a
vodka isn't it smirnoff okay
smell of trickiness in the trickiness
that he played but his tactical ideas
and the aggressive approach was causing
um knee how many more problems and this
solid approach that that hike's adopting
but it is his style to play play in this
manner but maybe nihal is very well
suited for this this manner yeah i think
stylistically these two players are
actually quite similar they want to
uh just get a solid position for
themselves where there are no tactical
opportunities for their opponent and
they want to slowly outplay out maneuver
uh the the other side and we see the
catalan and you know vladimir kramnik is
somewhere watching this and like oh
please make me proud uh young guys and
what is this pun on a5 simon i mean this
a4 a5 you are gaining space but i'm not
really too familiar with this plan
i'm certainly no expert myself in the
catalan i'm i mean i guess the whole
idea of the a5 pawn is kind of this
weird minority attack
where you're using the the a and b pawn
to try and tie up black's c being a pawn
so if black ever moves the b pawn
you you can take on pass on and create
some weaknesses in black's position so
it's sort of a a space gaining tire
upper
if that's their terminology i don't know
if it is but um yeah
uh okay well that's the position has now
changed somewhat yeah it's bit well now
the a pawn looks very good to me
okay it's funny because now that black
is the only side of the dark square
bishop i'm like is it maybe potentially
bad but i'm thinking well down the road
like if i can trade queens then maybe i
can go after this a pawn right easily
he's going for it potentially right now
bishop c7 putting his eye on it but
actually i'm with you simon i think that
white's position is becoming a bit more
favorable the knight on d3 is
particularly good you can go to c5 if
that bishop ever moves but i guess that
bishop is here to stay on d6
yeah i mean it's a very solid structure
for both players here and uh the one
problem with placing that port on a5 as
well another problem is that white can't
do the minority attack with b4 b5 and in
these positions the move b4 b5 is a
standard way to attack on the queen side
of a pawn and a4 so um i'm kind of
thinking and i love h5 h5 is again
starting sort of some wing action on the
other board maybe even i'm preferring
black somewhat here because of the
easier plan of attack white can't attack
on the queen side black can on the king
side
and uh with the knight coming to g4 at
some moment it looks it looks very
pleasant actually and we should talk
about opposite colored bishops in end
games we often think oh it's just a draw
because they're working on other
diagonals but when you have the
potential of an attack having opposite
color of bishop is a good thing for the
attacking side because i can go after
the dark squares you can't defend them
yeah i mean white's done the best he can
by placing his knight on c5 but that
that that king of his you know it can
certainly come to some kind of harm and
you have this knight g4 and i like g6
you can even go king g7 rook h8 right
and and i i
i just feel that white's kind of planned
us here about the minority attack of
going b4 b5 so this a4 a5 plan
seems incorrect
is he going to go for e4 now is this is
this something
he's thinking i can't sit here i have to
do something here yeah i think this is a
plan more of desperation than of
aggression and it's a good one and it's
a good lesson for a lot of our viewers
when you are attacked sometimes you need
to break open something else so that you
can counter and here breaking open the
center will mean that black can't just
go rook h8 rook h7 other rook to h8 and
just go mate the white king i will play
e4 and now you'll have to deal with some
of my threats i do think that this is a
good idea all things considered but i
still really really like the l's
position
yeah i i mean you don't you don't really
want to defend passively and so far for
um this hasn't worked for hike
in the match he's kind of sat and waited
and that's why he's only got half a
point so
with the idea of maybe going rookie one
at least he's keeping me how thinking
about this e4 move and you and this is a
bit annoying because you've got to
constantly keep an eye on it when that
rook swings away from e8 you lose
control of e4 so that's probably the
time white will will aim to hit in the
center of the board
i i definitely agree with that and i'm
wondering for black do you play knight
e4 yourself to plant essentially a pawn
once you capture me
on e4 to stop your forward progress and
if you take with the knight on e4 this
b4 pawn is the target so i'm wondering
if i can play knight e4 pawn f5 and just
try to close the center as quickly as
possible before rerouting you know to
the king side with rocket ship
yeah it seems like a very good plan
actually knight e4 um it stops white's
one plan as well which is always quite
pleasant if your opponent's got a plan
you can stop it you're doing that thing
where you're just you know keeping them
under control and frustrating them into
into making mistakes so yeah i really
like knight e4 will will he play it i
mean neha's been so patient maybe he
doesn't want to play he can be overly
patient you have to do something at some
point um and i s he might be thinking
can i improve my position without
changing the structure uh and it's not
easy to do so i think i mean rook h8 e4
if e4 works
then you shouldn't be going for rook h8
of course
right because you're sort of just you're
showing your hand and you're just very
clearly going for the king-side attack
and if i start trading some pieces you
won't even have much of an attack and
it's not like black will be in huge
danger there but with the king on g7
maybe that diagonal will open up and he
says let me first take on g3 and think
about the rest a little bit later
yeah i mean i i i wouldn't personally
have taken on g3 because unless you have
a solid follow-up because you want to
have the move h3 and in some positions
and you're limiting your possibilities
and
it's always best to keep as many
possibilities as you can i don't think
white has ever taken your pawns so
it seems just a very small thing but
giving yourself a possibility of playing
pawn h4 to h3 it is a nice extra bonus
and it's these kind of things which will
lose your advantage if you keep doing it
but he's played your plan robert he's
put the knight into e4 which is uh
making progress like you say f5 coming
and then you can play rook to h8 was
certainly an attack against white's king
still
and you also have to be careful knight
takes f2 or knight takes g3 there are
sacrifices that now hike needs to keep
his eye on and i think he made a really
instructive point there about the
leaving the pawn on h4 i also would have
left that pawn there for the time being
because it didn't feel like white could
do anything about it but i guess nihal
saying hey very directly i have this
under control and still white has little
that he can do to fend him off
yes i mean
you know if black can just improve and
white what can white do here because you
haven't got this b5 move this this
pushing the pawn away five it just
didn't work very well he's come back now
which is it is he doing that he's done
this before isn't he's basically saying
i've got to sit here and wait
and now there is certainly knight g3 but
you only play knight g3 if it works
because you have a good position anyway
but does it work i mean it's tempting
certainly tempting
simon i always sacrifice people's pieces
you know when i'm commenting
right just let me do it knight g3 pawn
takes bishop g3 at the very least you
have two pawns for the sacrifice knight
e3 is weak h1 i mean
how many times you can tap me into it
how many times yes
and also i mean you could go queen g5
first then you're really getting ready
then aren't you i mean
with the queen on g5 it it's it's got
the trigger's going to be pulled there
yeah queen g5 is better i think that's
objectively a much better move um i do
like the look of knight takes g3 i like
it less than that the queen can come
over to g2 but you're right simon just
the calmer approach queen g5 it's not
really that calm you're threatening to
sacrifice things for okay go for
checkmate
well not too soon don't play rogue h8
yet because then e6 is yes
and the world taking on g3 and so he has
to give up that bishop but that bishop
is such a good defender of the king and
we're all like i mean this is again if
if black had a pawn on h4 here if we
just you know you could go h3 and put
the queen on f3 so for example that that
exchange but okay even this position
it must be good i mean it's practically
so hard to defend do you play with rook
f3 or do you play rook hey i'm not sure
here well navigate oh oh never never
yeah maybe rookie rookie seven first i
guess yeah queen five is a good move
because you give yourself the control
over e6 and the potential for all
directions but maybe hike is defending
this i don't really see a way forward at
least not that easily for black uh maybe
rook f7 rook f8 but can't white also
play like rook h4
and then
i guess i don't have time to double as
white that's the problem
yeah i mean white if white can double on
the h5 it's white who's going to take
over the initiative and he's he's done a
good he's definitely done a good
defensive job here he's uh he's done the
best he can white
um uh to get the structure
so
but he's gonna have to play rook f1 and
he's gonna have to wait here so i don't
think
black
still i still like black but it might
there might not be a way to break
through easily here
yeah actually i think that uh why is
things pretty well under control because
you can't pile up any more pressure on
the f2
maybe you should put your king on like
d8 and then and then
then you can sort of uh put your rook on
f3 actually not d8 put it on e7 i just
want to i want to go queen g5 and rook
f3 and not not lose my queen
so but that's that's not not easy to
achieve so
i i do like the idea of the the king
walk though right that's the i i think
but now okay the time now this is this
is actually and now that that's come off
it seems like white should be absolutely
fine so so knee house just with this
exchange basically saying okay i can't
be better anymore
and
can white be better though here can is
white now okay so he's gone
here and the b pawn is a is weak so it's
probably a draw right robert because
there's no way you can get through but
there could be some like rugby one king
h3 king oh he's not like right away no
that looked bad
and rook b1 oh this is really bad now
really bad
yeah even rook h8 rook h1 is is coming
yeah
and he's pulled one back brilliant
defense
check bam
beautiful thank you for the game yeah
and
now you just got to calculate e4
probably best here i think is that right
just to get the passport yeah okay and
king g4 just king e3 you you lose your
f1
it's very very simple very nice
well that i have to say a very
impressive game from height day he got
himself a little bit of trouble
um he defended in that game brilliantly
and he he really needed that win uh in a
position where he was certainly a bit
worse and um i think nihal's gonna be
very upset with that one from from his
positional play maybe this is the
turning point robert where hike can get
a bit of a role going
yeah actually it's two games in a row
there where you know nihal started up
two to nothing then they drew game three
but of course hike's position was very
bad in that game so surviving game three
probably gave hike a bit more confidence
he had a bad position in game four a
worse position it wasn't that terrible
but it didn't look very good and he not
only held that but won the game so
yeah you start feeling a lot better you
can take a breath saying hey i'm not
just going to get dominated in this
match
yes and it's not getting your first win
on the board is so important because uh
you know you you will you can get
demoralized of course you can it's a
mental game so now now he can relax a
bit more and play as normal stuff and
this is
quite a solid variation of the slav
defense knight b6 a relatively sort of
modern idea um
and it is it's now a standard position
where f free's normal right rockets yeah
i was wondering what took him so long to
make that move because f35 e4 is quite
typical but knight d7 played immediately
by hike so it seems like hike knows what
he's doing and maybe nihal is caught off
guard
yes possibly i mean i think one line
here okay has taken that one he could
have gone e4 anyway but he's again
going for any risk-free strategy where
he's not allowing black to take on e5
himself
with the pawn coming to be for black's
probably gonna break with e5 this is
black's idea some something like that so
it doesn't get too
too uncomfortable for space
yeah that's that would seem to be
reasonable and it's interesting to me
simon that now hike is thinking about
how to recapture so either this is just
uh inaccurate move by
nihal or haiku's bluffing to some extent
where he doesn't really know the ins and
outs of this line
yeah i mean
i i guess the knight on b6 is is a bit
problematic now that's why maybe knight
takes d7 and some e5 idea could have
been uh
a more a better way to play i don't know
the theory here but that knight is is is
wobbly and black hasn't castled you know
white's got the center i i like white's
position here a lot so do i and i'm
looking at harry the h pawn i'm thinking
h4 is a moment as well like why can't i
just push on both sides of the board
here exactly do the same as you did
before right h4 and a4 get get them
moving um
and okay so now you've got to think
about d5 does is d5 working or not uh
you don't i mean so far neha's been very
patient and he hasn't wanted to change
the structure when he's got like a small
advantage
but
this i like i like that he's played this
now because i think it's you know i was
getting a bit worried he's being too
patient you've got to push at the right
time and this this must be the right
move to play it just feels totally right
oh yeah you can even follow bishop to c4
because you can never take with the c
pawn the c pawn is needed to keep uh the
piece out of b5 as soon as you take on
d5 here comes bishop b5 winning your
queen so maybe bishop c4 another move
you could play as queen d4 and then
just gain space in the center and stop
that bishop from developing because
you're attacking the pawn on g7 so
actually 24 is surprisingly annoying
yeah because the the only plan black's
got here is to move the bishop in f8 and
get castled and if he can do that if he
can get castle he's okay so i really
like your queen d4 queen d4 stopping
your opponent's plan and this this is uh
aiming for a small advantage but i i
felt that white could have aimed for
more with uh with black's king
being in the worst situation there
because white can castle quickly
swapping queens off
it's going to give white something
definitely uh there's no doubt about
that without pawn on c6 but it's not a
big advantage anymore the other
positional problem though black does
have here which often occurs in this
variation is that bishop on g6 i mean
i'm not a master of the theoretical side
but the bishop on g6
is a really horrible piece because it's
blocked out by white's pawn structure so
this these are the problems black has
here yeah and this what's going to
happen is in addition to what simon was
just saying is you're going to take back
on c6 once white takes this queen and
interesting that nihal is sitting here
really trying to figure out how to
capture back because his king on c2 for
this very reason what i was about to say
is you have a semi-open b file uh for
the black rook and that pawn on b2 is a
backwards pawn so you could get in some
trouble there and the b4 square he just
put his bishop there i would much prefer
if i could get my knight to that square
somehow
here we come here comes our friend harry
and uh i think that moves h4 h5
definitely help white because
i was thinking black might try this f5
move or something the f pawn and then
then it sort of weakened his structure
by playing h5 um knee how playing very
sensible good moves this is his strategy
just play good moves nothing
particularly flashy it's a good strategy
that isn't it robert something something
i should probably uh try more myself
in my games you know i was like can he
teach us because uh he's making it look
easy and you it is right from the very
start of this match where hike is an
amazing player and nihal is just like
clearly to me being the better of the
two just today not overall classical
rating feed a wise they're about the
same it's i think they're both in the 26
20s incredibly talented players but in
this match after four games i have felt
the power of neil he's been really
dictating the course of the games and
here is no exception to that his
position is better with white he has
obtained a pull here and i would think
about playing h5 to force this bishop
back all the way to h7 because the
bishop doesn't look so thrilled to be
sitting in front of the rook out there
yeah i agree with everything you said
there robert and um it does seem like
knee house on on form and one one of the
biggest skills is actually i mean
uh making a game look easy and uh a lot
of people sort of including myself i do
like the sacrificial games my favorite
world champion being like macau tau
but i really appreciate the players who
make chess look easy like mickey adams
english grand master springs to mind
when you watch his game she kind of or i
kind of think well what did he do there
what did he do he didn't do anything
impressive there but he just crushes
2700 by doing nothing impressive oh
what's this move okay so
the knight is trying to get a bid for
freedom and making chess look easy is is
so hard to do
it really is yeah actually i say this
often that uh people ask me which
players inspired you you know who are
your favorite players michael adams
since i was a kid is one of my favorite
players 100
and it's because of exactly i would look
at his games and be like what did his
opponent do wrong like how did he win
and win in 35 moves with white seemingly
without doing much of anything and
another player like that is lanier
dominguez i watch okay he plays this in
some sharper lines but oftentimes i see
him just grind people down and i look
i'm like wait what that was like a
nothing game but he wins and he makes it
look like his opponent was 200 points
lower rated than he actually is yeah yes
when you're not sure and i mean when you
when you lose a game yourself like
if i lose a game and i know i've done
something wrong it's like okay uh i i i
can sort of get over that in the future
but when i've played mickey adams before
and i lost the game i'm like hanging me
i don't think i did anything wrong there
how did i lose and i'm like
wow and i'm like and it really confuses
me and i'm like don't do that to me it's
not fair you know don't show your
strength so much and it's like wow you
know it's really impressive he's really
impressed me so go check him out if you
don't know him uh mickey adams is games
so yeah honestly players like they just
make you feel like you don't understand
chess and that's that's such a bad
feeling it's like wait wait yes i have
this title next to me that's a grand
master title but you just made me feel
like i i'm learning the game anew it's
honestly refreshing and that's why i
love studying their games and
niall starring right now he could try to
do that with the white piece in this
game because now that black is castled
but this bishop is stuck out here on h7
you have to like white's
chances here so grind
hiked out
yeah certainly i mean you know black has
this one idea of trying to do something
on the b file but um this is very easy
to defend and black's pawn structure is
worse the pawn on a5 the pawn on c6
both potential targets and
i think nihal was trying to go 92 maybe
knight d4 just trying to find somewhere
for that knight it's one idea um i also
quite like the idea just going g4 but
maybe he doesn't want to give away some
squares there
he's very patient look at this bishop e2
just attacking the knight just you know
very very sort of simply sort of saying
what are you doing and now he comes to
c4 so that the bishop can't be attacked
i mean that is some maneuvering there i
mean that is so subtle guys i mean
robert that's it that's really
really you know
special i feel he knows he wants his
bishop on c4 but bishop c4 right away
would have been it by knight e5 hitting
the bishop and the pawn so he retreats
his bishop first and then oh that's just
wonderful play there and black is trying
to make progress himself he's attacking
the pawn on a b3 here i play rook to b1
which is a very nihal type of move right
just like quiet don't take on c5 yet if
i don't really have to he may okay he
does take on c5 but rook do you want
which how can we go he's gotta watch his
time hasn't he again i mean i know he's
very quick and uh he has given up the
bishop player robert but the bishop on
h7 it's not a big deal i i feel the
bishop on h7 is really bad um
but he's got to just keep an eye on his
clock you know you can you can forget
about it
yeah and the the look at the difference
in the rooks here the works in the d
file that can go into d7 the rooks in
the b file you're staring into a
protected pawn on b3 so just a much
bishop a6 okay i hung the b3 bomb so i
was just saying how you're staring at
nothing but if i move my bishop way too
soon
you get me
what about this
yeah i i think he's going to try to find
a good square for his knight and if you
can get his knight to c4 somehow then uh
that seems like a good square because
he's got he doesn't really want to move
his pawns i feel black's maybe not doing
anything so how do you get it to c4
uh not easily maybe knight b1 is this
the knee how move you know knight b1 d2
c4 uh that's the kind of thing i would
okay i expect me how to play okay
black's done something drastic though
he's done something drastic yeah and i
think e5 as well just to trade the
bishops and bring my knight into e4 so
sure he does oh very nice yeah very nice
this is a much simpler way to play and
you do get rid of the bad bishop of
blacks but you you gain
this
i mean now you split black spawns on the
king side as well um five seconds oh my
gosh it means more quickly this could be
very bad
and now the king is coming
this is where hike's dangerous when he
starts to sniff that activity and he's
very good at getting oh look at that the
king is running right up the c file oh
nice move nice idea
oh my gosh that was like a e5 only try
yeah very nice for a bit yeah i thought
that hike was about to you know take
this one honestly and then he overlooks
96 check and just here comes the very
easy moves c5 king takes c6
yes uh
that king f5 is just premature and he
didn't use his time advantage well there
i mean actually in some respects
you know this is a big mistake you can
do over the board as well and the big
mistake is you can
play badly in your opponent's time
trouble and in that situation it was
hayek who blundered in his opponent's
time trouble
and uh this is actually an easy win you
get your rook behind the past pawn
there's no way you can just stop the
simple plan that rob's pointed out he's
trying something he's got to try
something right yes and he's hoping oh
he's no time let me you know try to
trick him swindle him here but you can
read david smith's book on swindles all
you want you're not going to get this
one
you have to have a
very big swindle here
super swindle because uh yeah
here it goes and king east but this
pawns are actually a little bit more
annoying than i'm actually going credit
for
he's doing his best and making this a
little bit okay nice that was beautiful
he's done it again little little bit of
a very nice end game play these little
moves which are sort of just to push
your opponent's pieces offside
and uh that's wonderful
if e2 you go rookie one and now this one
is going to
simply win those black pawns
check and then you get your queen or
rookie one same idea queen me thank you
wow
he has i mean the way he turned that
around but it honestly was hike's fault
we'll pull up the analysis board just
very quickly to show that position uh
where
i mean knight d6 check happened and then
it all went south so at this point here
instead of king f5 something you're
right just think a little bit maybe rook
b8 and just avoid 96 so that you can
even bring your rook to the king side
with h4
it makes a lot of sense because white's
pawns are on those dark squares and that
h4 move is a great lever to to to weaken
them and i think hike would have been
very much in the game there especially
using that time advantage in a sensible
way if he if he hadn't played this king
king f5 blunder and that's big i mean
how much time do we have left we have
half an hour left roberts and we we kind
of thought that you know this might be
actually a segment where hike has to
kind of win because we put nihao at
being the stronger player slightly in
the in the bullet i mean there's not
much between these guys but nihal is is
really really jumping ahead and it's
three and a half one and a half already
yeah it's a super impressive start for
him and in this game this is a little
bit odd to me knight h5 bishop g5 it has
in to some extent a king's indian vibe
but it's from the italian game so
f5 is probably on the docket that's what
you know we'll try to uh organize here
move his king away from the g8 square
but this is
this is strange to me
yeah i mean
i'm not an expert on these structures at
all and certainly not on this structure
i i don't know it's a very
unique way to play but they do say that
the dark square bishop of blacks is
often a bad piece because you know like
a king's indian it can be a bad piece
stuck behind a pawn on e5 so
positionally speaking you know trying to
try to get rid of that bishop makes
sense um
and
with the knight coming into f4 uh i i
was going to say i like black's position
but i i i think it's kind of normal
black white white hasn't done anything
wrong here so again white can't be doing
badly surely so you're saying we should
call it mickey adams because you know he
hasn't done anything wrong but sometimes
the game ends even when it feels like
that's the case that's it yeah i mean
get up mickey on the dog and blower
that's the phone if anyone's not sure
what that means
um well rookie one i guess he's just
going to try to get the knight to f1 in
in standard standard fashion like this
and
the case yeah
okay you want to play d4 for white but
right now black has too many attackers
on the square yeah
and it's black is black gonna try to
okay i was gonna say black could go
super aggressive with g5 and try to get
g you know h5 g4 but i don't like this
with the f5 square it looks
anti-positional sometimes when you push
a pawn
um you have to remember every pawn move
you you make weakens a square you know
and pushing the g pawn because f5 and h5
and you just got to make sure your
opponent can't take advantage of those
and that that seems like a positional
mistake actually i want to be aggressive
robert you know me i want to push i want
i want to give them a push so should we
start with h5 perhaps and that way
you're
waiting on why but white's move is going
to be 93 regardless so h5 doesn't
actually help against that threat
yeah
and i i guess if white can swap off
safely that knight on f4 or
kick it back with g3 then it's actually
gonna be black's pieces which which look
funny you can't do g3 easily now knight
to g1 is another source is that another
idea they play in these positions to
play g3 again it looks really odd to me
um
but okay bishop g bishop b5 interesting
robert i i guess he's looking at the d4
square because he moved bishop b5
instantly there wasn't even a moment's
thought there but now i'm liking your g5
edit assignment because white's pieces
have shifted away from the king side and
blacks have come towards the king side
so g5 feels just about right at this
point
it's a very practical move isn't it i
mean in this time limit it's much more
fun to attack we haven't seen nihal go
for these kind of attacks so he's doing
it in more knee how style just putting
his pieces on good squares
not you know not not committing to a
pawn move that might weaken a square
it's very again it's it's so mature way
of playing but i don't think i'd be able
to resist pushing those king side pawns
in the position i think they'd be
launched a couple of moves ago
like this isn't that position where
we're looking at g5 he'll be like let me
play king g7 first you know be
preemptive so that uh i can play g5 next
if i need to or you know play h5 he oh
he's done it yeah come on
at last at last he's put he's decided
it's time to have a go so uh
so is this a good move or a bad move
that that's that's what we're gonna find
out very soon right it looks to me like
it's a good move because this knight on
e7 can come to g6 and then watch out for
sacrifices over there on g2 and f2 is
what i'm looking at h5 as well right
this does resemble one of my favorite my
favorite openings the black the so
called black line which uh is this kind
of very dangerous club player opening
where you play like the the sort of this
this set up with black with the knight
on f4 and you just try to blow white
away by playing by playing h5 g4 and um
again it's whoever's the other thing in
chess is you don't necessarily always
have to have the advantage to have the
better chances you have to have the
position that is easier to play
and
even if the position is slightly worse
for you if your position is easier to
play it's you know quicker time limits
even more so that gives you that better
practical game computers won't tell you
this but black's position is easier to
play here certainly
not a thousand percent in agreement
especially in a blitz game you know if
you talk about classical chess then it's
like you have to really think about the
consequence of your actions but in blitz
your opponent is often just feeling
insecure about their king safety when
there's a knight in f4 pawns storming
down the board here and knight g1 you
had mentioned this move simon it allows
for g3 it also opens up the queen to the
h5 pawn and the g4 square so g4 not so
easy to accomplish but i'm looking at
this i'm saying wait
why can't i not play g4 you take on g4
queen h4 check and that probably just
would be the game
that's scary yeah
okay will you play g4 well g4 is is is
the move you certainly want to play
anyway
and as robert you pointed out that that
allows the black queen over to h4 has he
seen this if he's if he's seen this idea
he will play it
you know it's it's he's of course he's
seen it he's playing so well of course
he's seen it why don't i even question
the house it's ridiculous to question
him you know people people overlook
things every now and then and i think we
should point out and i was about to say
that g3 is often a move played by white
giving up the h3 pawn because after g3
knight h3 knight takes pawn takes a
situation like this arises where it
looks like black has an extra pawn but
that's not what's important rook f1
white can just strike back with f4 and
it's white who has a much better
position despite black's extra pawn on
h3
yeah that pawn on h3 is the typical it's
actually better having one of your
opponent's pawns on that square than
your own pawn they say when when you're
being attacked because
your opponent's pawn blocks your king
better because they can't your opponent
can't capture their own pawn but he can
capture one of your pawns in front of
your king so that you know it's a very
good defensive mechanism there of
allowing your your opponent to put a
pawn in front of your king tucking your
king behind it and you can use it as a
blockade
a 100 true and here this is the case
white plays h4 black is immediately
sacrificing the knight he's not thinking
about that surely no way and is black
going to play f5 as well can we just
bring all of our forces into the attack
well i think he wants to he wants to
play five and just open it up so
white didn't play this movie okay so f5
is kind of
is critical here uh i feel yeah just
just going for it and he's played it
he's played it without any this is the
thing when you've won a couple of games
you're much more confident you can see
that nihal's playing very confidently
here with these moves on the king's side
he's a confident guy anyway i mean you
should be at that age it's when when you
get to our range robert the doubts start
creeping in you know yeah you know you
know am i really able to win this game
but he
of course he is just an amazing player
and he knows it but in this moment
this could be a chance for him because
i'm looking at the clock and yeah it's a
complex position and hikes a little bit
ahead and it feels like nihal is more
prone to getting himself into time
trouble
yeah well this is a big question should
have should have uh of bishop takes f5
being played because that is a pawn on
g4 if white can win the pawn he will win
the pawn and uh niehaus now got the
question to answer i mean he's got some
play on the h
uh by sacrificing that pawn with you
know maybe he should have gone king g7
earlier robert right because if he had
gone king g7 early and the same kind of
mess that occurred it he would have rook
to h8 in a lot of positions but um you
know maybe maybe actually you well
because you said king you said maybe
knight h6 is a clever move here because
i'm giving you my pawn on h5 but i'll
throw in a knight g4 check and so
uh well that is me asking did he just
take on you for now i clicked on the
square but i wanted to play knight h6
and then
give up a pawn you said before you know
if you it's your opponent's pawn there
you can end up capturing it but he goes
for this trade and what is happening
here
well it seems like white's over the
worst but black has an initiative
um
in this position but i mean uh does he
have an initiative i mean i guess he's
got to get a rook to h8 and then the
white king sits on
g2 but the time again you're right this
time this time's going to make it very
tricky for knee hell
because if you don't find the right way
to play this position then you're just
worse
and um
does he have a good move now how about
knight g7 with a queen can i take on g6
queen h3 this is getting well it's good
it's got three seconds he's got to move
he's got to move okay now that could
just be over right yeah that is that is
over here okay
wow that went downhill very quickly for
me how so i mean
really well played by height to again
his defensive skills have proven to be
quite impressive at the moment to keep
himself in this match and
he's he should win this one now yeah
he's of a piece and he's using his time
wisely which he did not do in the
previous game where he allowed that 96
check so that was a good pause by hike
so that he could just convert his
winning position
yeah
so white's a piece up and white's also
got this very clever knight g5 move rook
h1 so
it's nice being a piece up when you have
the attack as well and what is going to
be two pieces up there so that was a
really important game there for hike
robert i think to get back into knee
house seemed to play very well but he
he spent a lot of time and he didn't
find the right blow later on yeah he's
just been doing that in several games
now where he's had a good position or
promising position and yes it's super
complicated he's trying to figure out
the exact right move but he's getting
himself in too much time trouble to
finish the game off so i do think that
hike has proven very sturdy in time
trouble situations for the most part and
neil of course does the lead but i would
keep an eye on that simon especially as
we get into quicker time controls yeah i
mean nihal's going to have to up the
pace in the next game i mean the next
segment the free three minute segment
um
and
let's remember if hike now wins this
game he's leveled the score he's leveled
the score so
it's kind of pretty much standard
position where white's
meant to be a little bit better because
this is one case where the central pawns
are good if you can remember us talking
about central pawns being weak before in
this situation as robert pointed out
those pawns grab a lot of squares and
white can sort of put his pieces behind
him
and they sort of uh can slowly move
forward so it's certainly a little
advantage of white but black's going
super solid here
right maybe maybe we've seen the game
that nihal lost there was when knee how
didn't go solid maybe hike should be
trying to get nihal
out of these super solid positions
that'd be my little bit of advice you
know try to mix it up a little bit more
against knee hell um
that that would be you know if i was
there able to give hike advice that's
what i'd say
and that was actually one of the
comments you read earlier was saying
just as much as smirnov gave nihal some
issues because he was playing more
tactical positions and tricky in a sense
and here
hike keeps going to these
very not casual positions but more
closed positions where you're looking at
the little pawn breaks rather than any
kind of sacrifice so
the last game was different because that
did get tactical and nihal spent too
much time and here we have just a nice
little positional advantage for white
with a rook on d1
and a queen on d8 the rook almost always
wins that battle
yes well okay so c5 has been played and
the rook went to d1 to try to stop such
a break as this but um you have to now
take with a bishop you'd rather take the
knight and now okay night knight comes
in
there's some
knight h7 stuff it looks like right and
you got knight e4 as well that's the
positionally sort of founding of it just
to centralize that knight at the same
time yeah i'll just show very quickly
like if you play rook to e8 i can i
think just take your pawn on h7 because
after we trade everything out here i
have queen d3 check winning the knight
on d7 not defended so i can win a pawn
in that manner
right
so rookie also doesn't make too much
sense but
just trying to show one of white's ideas
taxi so h6 was played
and just kicking that one away and now
centralizing
the d6 square is white
for the taking you can take this bishop
on z5 for the two bishops advantage
i definitely prefer nihal's position i
think he does
too because he's well ahead in the clock
yeah i mean one thing he's always got
here he can he i mean he doesn't maybe
want to grab the bishop on c5 because
suddenly black's knight on d7 comes to
life
uh we talk about the advantage of the
two bishops but
you don't always you know you don't
always want to do that you know
sometimes the knight can be better here
um
i mean it's not i mean this is a
standardish position black can't be
doing that badly either here uh white
what what's white doing can you get a
king-side attack i mean again i'm always
looking at the king this is one of my
problems i need so i need to i need to
grow up a little bit and play like knee
hell i need to play like my juniors not
my seniors no from the juniors not the
seniors and but i mean something i'd be
thinking of here is rook ac1 bishop b1
queen c2 but maybe it doesn't even do
anything but you know just like getting
that diagonal towards black's king
probably a better way to play though oh
that does make sense and also i'm
looking at the d6 square can i throw in
knight d6 right now because to somebody
like wait you're just giving me a free
piece but just to of course uh show you
that you can't take on d6 without losing
your queen i said rook always wins the
stair down with the queen bishop h7
check gets rid of the bishop and thank
you for the queen so uh 96 is a move
that you can consider here it doesn't
really do much it attacks the bishop the
bishop can just move away so i'm also
you need to grow up for my one with
threats
well we all love we all love the cheapo
don't we i mean
unfortunately we're kind of trained
well you know we're taught from a young
age get don't go for scholars mate
because it's stupid but we all love a
cheapo everyone loves a cheapo
you know no matter what age you can't
get out of that habit and
i certainly can't if i see a little
cheapo i'm very tempted to give it a go
um but you should never do cheapos it
makes your position worse this is a big
problem that i again i think lower rated
players play they they play sort of um
tricky moves
and they're hoping their opponent
doesn't find the right answer you should
always assume your opponent's going to
find the right move always it's the only
way to improve even if you get your
cheap hosing
and i i just saw the uh evaluation bar
shoot in black's favor after this a4
move because that's your b4 i wonder if
um missed that for a5 there's just queen
c6 and there's a checkmate threat down
on g2 in addition to uh the knight on c3
being under attack so essentially a5
queen c6 you would like to take on f6
with check but after the knight takes
back you can't block my checkmating
threat down on g2 and your knight is in
trouble
yeah that's that's a nice plan that one
and all of a sudden that means black
might be gaining the digit because white
has to take on f6 and put his knight on
this
bad square okay if that knight gets to
c4 he's okay but black has the activity
this might be his chance to try and do
something before white can uh play these
two moves so he's done it queen c6
threatening mate
good move don't wonder that one uh so
don't play knight to d2 you need to
protect the actual g2 square f3 weakens
e3 and may allow a knight d5 move so
queen f1 said but
yeah this is looking really good for
black now because white's pieces are are
just not
really sitting pretty and is he just is
he just giving that pawn he does yes
okay
i i would definitely take it and i
wouldn't think too long ago because he
does take it and i think white is even
forced to trade the queens
two bishops and now the bishop on d5
look at that piece
that's a lovely piece i mean
now that black's got rid of the e pawn
uh that bishop on d5 just is is probably
the winning piece yeah uh must be the
winning piece you would need to put that
e pawn back up by e4 to kick it out you
don't have an e pawn and this is just
horrible
foreign match this one which is i think
we've got time for probably just one
more game after this one so it's very
close match and
um
you know we were saying how well nihal
has been playing but hikers hikes been
doing is to be doing his stuff and this
game's shown his kind of style of just
played
of just playing this this way where he's
playing sensible moves and he's taking
his opportunities when he gets them he's
defending very well
um
it's going to be a very close match very
close match yes and
i mean i i just i'm thinking about the
beginning of the match where nihal was
just seemingly winning
in uh the first he won the first two and
then felt like he was
keeping it up and then game three when
hike held that draw and then in game
four when he turned a disadvantage into
a win it does just seem like hike has
been playing better in some critical
moments in recent games and here is no
exception to that i mean look how long
i'm looking at time here that nihal
spent a minute and 49 seconds and played
a4 which immediately cost him uh his
position so i think that hike is
improving and right now nihal is
struggling he's floundering quite a bit
yeah i totally agree and this is these
are the points aren't they in the match
when you're playing the same opponent
time again you get these kind of runs
and knee how had a bit of a run to start
and if he gets a little bit despondent
here a little bit annoyed it could be
now hike's time to take over the
initiative in the match situation he's
going to level it with this probably
like say one more game after this left
in the five minute section
um
i mean blacks are pawn up here the
bishop on d5 is great uh bishop on c3 is
great it should be quite simply winning
as long as black doesn't uh as long as
he doesn't do something silly here
and he went knight f1 knight c4 he would
allow the capture on c4 with check but
his idea clearly is to go knight to e3
and if rook to d7 you still have knight
e3 so
that's what neal's hoping for i guess
there are some outside opportunities to
hold this game
they just don't feel very likely because
if you can trade off maybe a pair of
minor pieces then you're only down one
pawn and there are certain end games
right simon where you're down upon but
you still have very good chances to hold
especially like rook in three versus
rook and four type of situations
yeah
yeah black black's still squeezing away
though knight e3 is a good place for the
knight
um
you want to get rid of that bishop that
bishop's been so annoying throughout the
game if you can get rid of that bishop i
agree all of a sudden it's like okay
there's there's chances to to maybe hold
some ending um if you can get rid of
that so i expect black will if he can
play just play something like bishop c6
trying to get a rook into d2
uh along those lines
if you guys you know then they have come
to c4 as a response and that's the
square you've been talking about all
along the c4 square
yeah okay so now we get a pure ending so
this is i don't know i mean it it's
still very good for black of course it's
good for black because black's got the
space advantage and now we're okay the
rook's coming to d2 that is a major rook
he hasn't got the the light square
bishop but a rook on the seventh rank
should be should be doing the job bring
the king go rook b2 at the right moment
or something i guess yeah yeah the rook
on b1 just can't move because any time
it does your rook b2 you win the b3 pawn
and if that's the situation you're
completely frozen like king e6 b5
just bring that king in
yeah
i don't think exchanging bishops helps
here
so and i guess black's gonna play e4 at
the right moment so now rook b2 is is
the critical move to play so bishop c5
he's you know he's creating some chances
for himself here take on a6
so can you go king f5 do you want to put
your king there but a g4 checkmate
you if you forget with the ampersand
that would be so funny if you saw any
games g4
that's actually happened to me before
not quite like that but i checked my
opponent at the british championships
and he castled and i i was really
confused because i put him in check he
castled his king i'm like how did i miss
that move he's got a really good
position i just misplaced my queen and
then like 10 minutes later i realized
actually he couldn't castle because he
was in check so yeah that's like
um bishop v7 is the running rookie to
meet though
look how quickly he saw rookie to an e4
yeah
oh yeah he was expecting that one
so nihal's fighting he's fighting away
here
yes stills chances but this f pawn look
at that he doesn't care about the g5
pawn he's going to try and promote as
quickly as possible
wise a wise choice there i mean you
can't stop they can't stop these pawns
no the bishop specialist either is so
good covering this one yeah
and now can you just play
f okay well i guess knee how's going to
take no he can't do that even
oh nice rook to three check good
inclusion there by hiking he's just
winning the game because the rook is
defended on d3 by this new korean
very nice game by hike and it's now
three and a half all wow three and a
half all and this is most likely the
last game at a five minute segment so
can either player
get an advantage before then the speed
heightens to three minute each
and hike is uh hiker's back in it i mean
he's really he's a real tough competitor
as hike
um i actually once saw in that position
knight bd7 being played um knight d6
check by 2200 player in round one it was
quite funny he's playing he's playing uh
richard right yeah richard reports
that's it he's an english player and he
played and this is his one chance to
play someone so strong and he played
knight d7
that was the end of the game round one
oh dear embarrassing he was 22 i mean he
was 2250 the guy who allowed this
unbelievable
that must be one of the most
heartbreaking experiences ever you have
such a great opportunity to play one of
the world's best that's a rare chance
for a player in that rating range and
then you blunder check me on the game
move four or five and then yeah i
haven't seen him play much chess after
that i have to say oh
poor guy
um
interesting cara con we haven't seen
this kind of position before this is
this is quite a unique to the match so
far because it's it's going to get it
well it's already getting quite sharp um
the structure is very unbalanced
but black's trying to get an attack
going yeah i wouldn't have expected neil
to play this from the black side based
on the repertoire we've seen him use
thus far in the match but now we're here
and i don't really mind black's position
i think that the king is quite safe on
e8 you can choose uh which way to castle
but the problem will be in the future of
these double left bonds
yeah so he's got he's gone decided to go
queen side as well
um
white it's funny because white's pawns
haven't moved very far whatsoever
you know they're all sort of stuck on
the second rank but he's very solid and
he's he's got his now development coming
in with bishop g2
later on as robert pointed out the f
pawn could be a little bit weak
um maybe there's knight d4 idea at the
right moment and then f4 on knight h4
and f4
but it's it's it's fairly even so far
this one i think it's harder for black
to play because look at his last move
bishop a3 to e7 he clearly wants to move
his knight next and keep the pawn
defended but i don't really know what
black's plan is i see some moves i mean
i can move my knight out i can move my
rook somewhere but what's my actual plan
whereas you just mentioned a couple ones
for what like knight d4 followed by f4
knight h4 just to go after this bishop
for my bishop on g2 for one nine h4
and i i just feel like the immediate
position feels favorable for white
yeah certainly i mean i neha would like
to go like knight b6 knight d5 knight b4
but
you know this is going to take a lot of
moves and
if white can get rid of the bishop on f5
it probably just stops that plan
so
that's maybe what he's trying to do but
knight b6 knight d5
the knight would certainly be better on
d5 but white's going to get his moving
first and he has he's got knight d4 at
the moment
makes sense and bishop g6 the that's why
i didn't really love the nd4 compared to
h4 is i thought that you know taking the
bishop would be part of your plan
because if that bishop stays here too
long there could be an issue on the
queen side which is where white's king
resides
yeah
it's one of those positions where you'd
like to play you know like something
takes c6 i mean uh
i'm just wondering if if there is if
there was a bishop take c6 fret there
with knight takes coming i mean that's
why i think black's over defended the
bishop on on e7 here
um
so h4 played and
yes i i certainly think white's a little
bit better now he black's gone rather
passive and he's got this now he's
played h5 that pawn on h5 in an ending
could also be a little bit weak to sort
of you can go bishop f3 and try to take
it at the right time but uh white
doesn't have any pawns that are a
weakness at all sure and i was going to
add that you can play g4 as spring free
your h-pawn and that's the problem with
having double pawns if there's a pawn on
g7 anytime there's g4 i just take and my
g pawn will cover the h file but now if
i get g4 at the right time then comes h5
h6 and so on that pawn just translates
yeah so i suppose you could even go f3
and g4 with that idea in mind then you
know just one one simple way to play so
easier for white to play but nihal in
this game has got the time advantage
he's still quite solid
um how is he going to deal with his
bishop e4 now i doesn't really want to
play f5 this is again a very clever
positional move i feel from white
because if black plays f5 okay he has
played it
maybe i said maybe i'm saying it you
know maybe
it's okay but bishop on g6 is now like
really bad it's really bad so white's
tempted me how into doing this
move to make that bishop bad
i wonder if the idea is that he'll play
f4 next because bishop d3 i could put my
knight on c5 and just try to take off
your
bishop there and so if i can play f4 i'm
trying to shatter your pawn structure on
the king's side for white so i'm with
you the bishop doesn't look very good
but perhaps it's just a temporary
situation though
yeah f4 looks like a good move to play
at the right point you know give a pawn
up to cause your opponent the pawn the
structural problems in the position
um and maybe after bishop f3 you have to
play like f4 right because i don't know
well there's e5 as well actually e5 is
quite nasty
i forgot about e5 e5 um
and the knight where's the knight gonna
go so okay this is this is uh these
pawns could actually be quite active
with e5 if if black can play e5 and like
some other pawn move they're they're
starting to they're starting to cramp
white's position a lot here i actually
quite like e5 right now because yeah uh
you know you're hitting this knight and
then you can even go e4 next and you can
put your bishop on f6 and hey the bishop
on g6 doesn't look so good but all your
other pieces look much better
yes and white's very cramped you know
take the space when you can hear as
black e5 e4 i like it go positive in the
position you should always try to play
the most positive moves if you can in a
position i i feel this is the right way
to go
um
but not if it weakens your position
that's that fine line of pushing but not
over extending
is he gonna go e5
maybe if it was after his runner wins
he'd be playing e5 immediately here
because he'd be a lot more confident and
this is where you've lost the game it's
the last game you're a little bit more
cautious and you don't want to commit to
sort of playing such a move because
you know you are moving those pawns are
they strong are they weak and he's i
guess he's trying to work that out now
and even though objectively that game
where he played uh you know g5 h5 g4 f5
all those moves objectively those were
good decisions he may have bad memories
of that and look he played bishop f6
probably uh in part as you said he's
lost a couple games lately so he's just
let me play a little bit more solidly
yeah
now again i i i guess he's he's
preparing e5 he wants to play e5 when
the bishop's now in a better square
uh if he doesn't play e5 i mean white's
ideal situation here if he could like
move that knight to e5 somehow uh you
know at the right moment and just play
against bishop on g6 but as soon as you
go knight f3 then e5 is is coming so
okay so queen e3 here
and there clearly was some tactic i saw
the bar jump up and down i don't know
what it was
but there may be some kind of knight
takes c6 oh knight takes c6 was
was there something interesting anyway
there
yeah i just i just saw the bar jump and
then go back down so clearly there's a
tactic there and the only one i see was
a knight takes c6 type of move so anyway
we get our bishop c6 something like that
probably knight c6 the knight was
hanging let's just go for it yeah
something like this
oh i made a blunder in the second move
oh so it doesn't like it anymore what
the
it had a huge evaluation problem with
these like engines on low depth because
they trick us i didn't think it worked
but then i trusted the evaluation bar i
do not like commentating with the
evaluation bar i've said this many times
same hand but
you know it's not my call and it's
tricky i should trust myself more you
darn evaluation bar over there can't
take you anywhere
i totally agree i mean um i know a lot
of people watching like the evaluation
bar because it gives them sort of an
idea of what's going on but there is a
major danger of and this is something
that so many players do and it really
really annoys me that they get so
addicted to the evaluation bar they're
not even looking at the ball they're
just looking at the bar you know and
they're just watching it go up and down
they go oh yeah black's just blunted
white's so bad and they don't even know
what they're talking about you know
they're
they're these little evaluation bar
junkies and
that's why it's nice just try to maybe
you know sometimes just don't look at it
look at the board make your own
judgments i mean you're not going to
gain anything by just uh concentrating
on the computer's evaluation uh it's a
nice indication at times though to see
what's happening but yeah
yeah it gives you um ideas sorry it
doesn't give you it gives you moves but
not ideas so especially in a position
that right here it's plus point two that
i would say that we would agree with
that like we don't think in those terms
we're like okay white is probably
slightly better but you actually have to
come up with ideas yourself and speaking
of ideas a4 is his idea just play a5 and
a6 yes because the only way to stop a6
for black would be to put your queen
there in which case the bishop would
have just walked back to f1 so a6 now
what's the claim here simon is it that
the space grab for white is beneficial
because i'm looking at this pawn a5 and
i'm thinking end game and that could be
a weakness rather than a string
yeah sure i mean uh
it's i mean you have got this b6 square
in some structures if you can get your
knight to c4 um you can try coming into
b6 or coming to b6 with your bishop so
white
white is is aiming for this but i don't
think he's going to be able to get it in
knee how playing knight g4
and
okay
it's a very weird position this one
they're doing these little you know it's
gonna it feels like it's just getting
ready to jump into life very soon and
now their time's going down
i can't predict what the result will be
here it's it's really like just brewing
brewing until the the crescendo here
yeah what is this rook takes e5 what a
sack because bishop we've had queen a7
and neon's clock he's only at 15 seconds
right now this is this is a great move i
don't think nihal should have got rid of
his dark square bishop there that was uh
and this is this is very dangerous okay
oh
bishop takes queen takes e5
love chess like this we're just getting
a series of trades simon e takes d5
yes keep that rook on the open file but
look at the bishop the bishop on g6 is
still a little bit funny right i mean
you can go f4 at the right time and you
probably have to but after like bishop
f3 um
black's advantage is the e file so as
long as he's got that e file it probably
does cancel everything out but a time
situation
you know he's gonna go king d2 and
rookie one right i mean
rook f6 okay he's got this g4 now
you might have to try that move and
to king
you gotta go g4 i think is a great try
especially in a bullet scramble right
now you gotta go g4 just so you get the
past h pawn in some positions just just
go for it easier plan to play you know
he's done it so you want it for a good
response good response definitely take
with until the past using the rook
oh this is now this is now risky i think
black if he gets black gets the king to
d5
rook behind the past pawn we've seen
this before surely black is now pushing
for the win oh yes and now you can't
play d5 for white because i just take
and actually a problem with the pawns on
a5 and c5 you can't create a passed pawn
rook c3 check roxy through check yeah oh
this also works oh oh
oh very nice that was a very clever move
now the pawn queens so knee how oh that
was that was a
i mean there were some crazy tactics
there to start with like hype played
this brilliant exchange stack but then
nihal
showed this great understanding of the
position because he could have like
tried to defend it but he gave back the
exchange immediately and then his end
game skills i mean heights and game
stills throughout this competition have
been great but knee how he showed some
brilliance to you but this is certainly
the critical moment you know when i said
it was brewing robert i think i said it
the right moment like bang it just
happened here right
so i mean what a sequence of moves there
where it looked like uh hike was being
the tricky one then neil said hey i'm
gonna calm myself down use most of my
remaining time and fend him off and
simon that's the end of the five plus
one so that was a very important win for
nihal because he got off such a blazing
hot start he then was just struggling
through the middle portion of the five
plus one he wins the last game he takes
a one game lead into the shorter time
controls
yeah definitely definitely and that's
that's a big lead you know that was that
was a really key game um
that is the end of the five minute
section so next it's three minute plus
one second move um
and it's hike's the one who's gonna pull
himself into gear in that section
he certainly does that was a time
scramble we'll see much more of those
coming up but for now we are going to
take a break and when we return we will
have the three plus one portion of this
junior speeches championship brought
match brought to you by chess.com and
chesky.com
[Music]
so
and we return ready for the three plus
one
portion of this junior speeches
championship match so far it's been a
great one neal is out to a lead and
simon he was the presumptive
champion if you will of this field when
smarter chess did the predictions you
know crunched the numbers it was neal
cern at the end of the day who was
supposed to lift the title and well hike
martial rosen wasn't even supposed to be
here according to the numbers
yeah i mean it's i find it's a smart
sort of you know chess thing that
they're using here for the predictions
it's very clever i mean i think it's got
nearly
every prediction right it's certainly
got the majority of them right and um so
niihau is is the predictive winner i
mean the thing is every close every
match is just so close
um
i mean
i i i mean at the moment he's looking
like still probably that's a good
opportunity for him to become winner
he's going that way
sam sevion is supposed to be his
finalist in the final i don't know
robert who's going to do it is he going
to do it well i guess you know we have
to
not call smart chess out necessarily but
sam7 did lose to alexis saranac so it's
going to be jeffrey zhang versus serrano
in the other semi-final awaiting the uh
of course the champion of this match and
well we're they don't even talk about
this anymore they're starting their
games so they're in
oh
i was wondering if we're going to get a
french much to my chagrin but i know you
like the french every now and then
i like a bit of french action yeah
it's fun now and again
not all the time but occasionally and
you can see already they they've both
picked up the pace uh they had this
position
uh
only in the last game i think it was uh
the one before the break c5 played again
um nihao
didn't get much there but he got some
kind of advantage with this knight g5
move was that right yes exactly right he
brought his knight g5 back to e4 and he
blundered when he made an eventual a4
move
i find this is one one thing that like
blitz is very good for in general i
don't think blitz is great improving
your all-round chest it can be but for
practicing our openings you sort of uh
especially against the same opponent it
can be very useful because
you can try to sort of improve on your
play you kind of know where you've gone
wrong and you can try out a different
idea in the next game so it's it's
certainly got its advantages blitz
for doing this kind of thing knight e4
ruxi1 is he going to go for bishop b1
and queen c2 i doubt it what's he going
to do here i kind of want it to happen
because you've mentioned i'm also
looking at bishop c7 it doesn't work i
don't think but i'm trying to drag the
queen onto a file where i can get a
discovery so not bishop c7 yet but i'm
looking at it i'm trying to make the
tactics happen
bishop c7 is a really funky move isn't
it i mean it's their bishop c7 trying to
use those rooks for black can get a rook
to c8 but i yeah it doesn't seem to
quite work here
um i mean black set up to me it might be
a bit worse but it is it's solid and
it's quite hard to break down
uh
i'm thinking now knee how's thinking as
well um you can see that hike has really
picked up the pace he's only spent like
five seconds getting to this position so
far
um and he needs to pick it up a little
bit very close match at the moment yeah
what caught me off guard in this game is
though they repeated the line on move 14
knight g5 and he all spent 18 seconds on
that move and you know he was expecting
this he just played it i don't know if
he during the break looked with an
engine or with his coach being like hey
can you tell me where i make a mistake
how can i improve but he's spending way
too much time with this oh definitely
maybe he hasn't adjusted as well as i
thought because this is the big thing
when you step from one time limit to the
other you've gotta you've gotta
get into it quickly um obviously if he
loses this game by going very short of
time it's gonna be bad but even in the
five minute section he was getting
shorter time so
this he's gonna have to pick up the pace
certainly during this uh one hour of the
three-minute blitz he's
he spent a minute and 24 seconds to play
bishop b1 so maybe there was some
tactical line that he was looking at
that i'm not giving enough credit for
but you cannot spend almost a minute and
a half on that kind of move
no certainly not
and um i i i mean again white white's
position it is fine but so is blacks
black doesn't really have any weaknesses
here black's developed the bishop on b7
is a lovely piece that black has
pointing across the board towards g2 so
this i mean this is the kind of opening
i don't think nihal should be playing
this particular line time and time again
personally because i i mean he lost that
last game in it and i don't think he's
got anything here and it's quite a
tricky position to play
for white even black smooth is a lot
more natural at this time you want to
play your moves quickly um i just feel
he shouldn't be playing this opening
again personally this variation yeah
that'd be my suggestion i think that he
will likely
mix it up in the future but right now
it's haiku spending a lot of time and i
guess the reason why is if the d6 square
is now white's for the taking because
you brought the bishop back and you look
at that there's tension with all of
these knights because if the knight on
f6 took on e4 the d7 knight was hanging
so quizzes rook on d8 which allows some
kind of knight to d6 but i guess he's
claiming i'll just drop my bishop back
nah please think he's he's definitely
got to think about your bishop c7 now
right
i mean
because he can't go queen d8 anymore
bishop c7 was like he's gonna probably
have to give his queen up for pieces was
he there or i don't know maybe the
knight can come to e7 i'm not sure that
was just confusing me i think he gets uh
a lot of people too many pieces right
yeah he does two minor pieces and the
rook for the queen that's a lot that's a
little much
too much okay so we see the trades
instead
yeah
i don't think why there's anything here
i i know white certainly doesn't have
anything i mean the bishop on b7 is
looking good as well i mean h3 is just
to move
saying okay i've got to make a move
quickly let's do something
but black has ways to improve his
position he can just exchange off as
well if he needs to but he's done his
queen c6 this is what he did last time
robert he did queen c6 last time and
uh
i think knee hell had to play e4 and e4
just lost the pawn and in this position
it's not as bad because e4 doesn't lose
a pawn but i mean you can go f3 but
queen c6 seems like a useful move for
black anyway threaten mates it's always
nice to frame
especially the quicker time controls
right yeah your opponent may be caught
off guard and he plays f3 but that
weakens e3 the good news compared to the
other game is the knight is still on c3
so in the other one the pawn had gone to
a4 and black's pawn was on b4 which is
much worse for nihal now his knight is
at least on a good square i'm looking at
bishop takes a3 at some point because
the knight loses defender but i guess uh
he decides just hey let me just bring my
rook to e8 first that smarter choice i
was thinking of e5 as well some rookie
eight you know sacked the pawn but then
bishop d4 like unfortunately gets in the
way of things but he's played it this
way um
and
it seems like black is making more of
the progress here personally
expanding in the center but white at
least has a grip on the e4 square here
this is this is holding it together for
knee how at the moment this square nice
central concreted point
and then move e6 to e5 that could cause
some problems if the bishops get traded
off so let's say we have an exchange in
e4 and then on b7 then i have the d5
square like plant my rook and that's
what i'm looking at now like uk plays e4
i thought even bishop e4 was possible
there giving yourself doubled isolated
pawns but in return you get that very
important d5 square i guess he's doing
it this way he's getting himself d5 he's
getting d5 which is which is something
i mean the pawn structure is very
symmetrical though and now black has
weighs in with like queen c4 etc but the
time the time situation
is is something i mean black black's
sneaking his way into that position
trying his best for sure
yeah the c2 c1 squares are under black's
control the queen on b3 is a nuisance i
think that bishop is a great move
because bishop g5 bishop f4 was the
threat
definitely
and now and also you know white can sort
of if he wants to okay bishop g5 anyway
has been played
i was thinking white could just try to
swap queens if he wants to i mean it
looks like black's got the better of it
but maybe there's nothing here actually
it's just it's very even
yeah queen c2 they may even throw a rook
d8 check just to you know scare you hope
you take my rook
actually this could go south for black
all of a sudden okay like isn't this
rook coming to d6 or the d7 in this g5
pawns under attack i think it was very
weird that he moved his queen backwards
there because he the black queen was so
active why is he retreated he's going to
come into f4 but this position
this position is is obviously it's a
support up now you've got to defend this
you've got to and actually this is not
so easy i think oh it's not easy at all
you can play a4 and just get this one or
it takes and take on b5 he'll have a
pass pawn you go h4
h3 that king can slide in the light
squares as well yeah
probably a draw probably should be a
draw but i mean
look at the time blank's got to defend
this one a little bit
right and oh watch out for beasts okay
don't play b7 too soon right you don't
want to rush that king h3 here
oh he hasn't played it because
king h3 yeah bring that king up all
right so you can't take it because it
would be h6 h6 h6 oh but it's qg6
there's king g6
okay
h6 look like a very clever idea though
didn't it i think it's winning anyway
but we don't go king of five
i thought that there might be some kind
of uh checkmating net against the white
king
but no now it's winning
okay
h7 and then h8 equals queen that's a
very nice end game play again i mean
these guys very nice play um
that was i mean that went from a
position where it's completely equal to
to uh black playing a couple of negative
moves queen when the big one there was
black retreating his queen out of that
danger zone and when you got such an
active piece going backwards i think it
was because uh you know
he wanted to avoid a draw there maybe
maybe he wanted to avoid some perpetual
queen c2 rook d2 but you know if the
draw is the best move to play you've got
to play it because queen c2 i think
would have led to a draw um with best
play but going passive here certainly a
big mistake no turn it around so quickly
because now white's controlling the open
file black is the one with the weak pawn
and a very nice conversion by knee
holland as we get to the current
position nihal up two points he's on the
black side of this one uh just standard
opening fair at this point and a4
typical move trying to chisel open the
queen side but that's why you play a6 if
white plays a5 you just push through to
b5
yes um more of a sort of london system
kind of set up here now that we're
seeing
this is a standard really london setup
pawn structure with black playing quite
actively in the center maybe with e5
coming on in a position
at the right moment here
that's the goal which is why in part the
bishop slides back to h2 so e5 doesn't
come with kind of full effect
yeah
black making the simple exchanges
um
is he going to go for e5 he is going for
e5
so
nihal not worried about that one the
problem with playing e5 for black is
after there's a mass exchange on e5 yeah
the d5 pawns weak right so
you know you've got your bishop the dark
square bishop as white outside of the
pawn structure a lot of these positions
like a slav but a bishop on h2 is a
really good piece in the slav it's often
on c1 where it's a really terrible piece
and that's why it's not easy for black
to break with e5 it might weaken black's
position rather than anything else uh
it's solid though if black does nothing
what's white doing does white have to
play b4 to to make progress well okay he
can do that but again you could weaken
yourself from the c file by doing that
one
exactly and that's why the rook came to
c8 preemptively queen comes to b3 black
can play c4 at some moment but i would
not do that releasing the tension feels
like a bad thing for black to do just
yet d takes c5 you cannot take with the
pawn on c5 because you lose the bishop
on b7 so after dc5 you'd have to take
with a piece at the very least you get
in you're no longer a symmetrical punch
structure you can't take with the knight
because the b6 pawn is hanging so i
would consider d65 if i'm trying to play
for a win and he does that he's played
it yeah
yeah and he's going for this the queen
takes is pretty much force because that
weakness on b6
um still a solid structure this is again
a little bit of shadow boxing really
going on here um
both sides
not
making major progress in the position
knight d4 black you could even say has a
bit of a better structure with more
central pawns and a bit more space to
maneuver but
at the moment nothing serious has
happened to either size position
yes because the base pawns are all safe
and sound right the b2 pawn hard to get
to f2 g2 all safe and you're not
attacking me so you know where to make
pro i don't know if i like that decision
that's a very committal decision taking
that you know giving up the bishop pair
but now
allowing black potential to attack on
well i'd say on the v8 h2 diagonal i
mean something like bishop bishop
dropping back there i i why give up the
bishop like that when there's no need to
was he really scared of that knight so
much it seemed it seemed odd robert i
agree
i yeah not offended he didn't want the
knight to jump to c4 i gather but this
bishop on e5 is such a great piece and
honestly simon i like your idea of just
swinging the bishop back to well now it
didn't make sense as much to go to b8
because the palm is on f4 but going for
that kind of plan looks good e5
certainly still a possibility for black
put my rook on e8 play e5 go after this
e3 pawn i love black's position here
yeah i mean white's trying to rely on
this knight on d4 to save him because
that knight on d4 you can only get rid
of it by exchanging the bishop for it
now so this is like his one big thing
and it doesn't look so bad for white
here i mean i've had these kind of
positions in the dutch this this now
resembles some kind of stonewall dutch
or something like this where
you know it's not terrible because e5
white's positioned himself to get that
counter play on the f-file um
why why this king g8 i don't understand
king g8 it seems peculiar to me and rook
a8 why oh rook defends support okay i
see that one
so yeah okay i had the same reaction
about king g8 i was like well what does
that help i guess he wants to give
himself some space on g7 with the bishop
yeah and he's gonna play f5
i think he i think he's going to try to
stop maybe any break with e4 if he can
but i like this g4 move this is just
like right he's played it straight away
he's he's doing this positive move on on
the king's side it might be a terrible
move but i still like it you know
it's sort of a it's a move that i'd have
to play myself just to just to push over
there um can you can you try to play e4
or f5 for white
again very careful about doing those
moves
but
i'm looking at that f5 square for black
as well like can black play f5 but
there's always danger of a queen g2 h4
h5 and you're creating some weaknesses
on that side of the board so i actually
don't see how black gets like active
here the bishop on b7 we know how that
bishop can get stuck behind his pawn on
d5 and then knight on d4 is blockading
it so all things considered
maybe white's position is turning around
the other very risky plan is to try f6
and e5 because that is one way you can
get rid of that knight okay he hasn't
gone for this and i assume that this
this was not the right way for black to
play because you've given white the open
file
and it i mean if you wanted to go e5
robert you should have done it earlier
surely when when white wasn't as well
positioned white has now got pressure
and as you're pointing out
he can i don't know if he can take there
immediately but queen f2 very natural
move could you take that i don't know
probably not it's hard to evaluate it
and especially with such little time in
your clock you think the two rocks are
better than the queen and especially
with the e3 pawn being so weak so
i just like black's position now because
you have at least a planet bishop h6 at
any moment can swing here hitting e3 he
plays it why not well that's a good move
yeah i missed that one oh
i missed e4 though
okay what's happening here okay f7 f7 is
coming in and the bishop's trying
it's really heating up now yeah knee how
again is behind on the clock but he
plays so well with his shorter time
so well okay rook takes f7 and oh what
is happening here so rook back to e7 i
guess but this certainly looked good for
white
queen bishop v3 watch out for that yeah
bishop b3 is a nasty one
can i just like slide my king up you
can't move bishop e3 because i broke up
a check your bishop is needed to defend
the square
oh my gosh
he plays king too
good good move well well well found
there robert the knight on d4 is very
strong if you can keep it there right
very strong you got bishop c2 as well
you've got i mean the bishop a8
white white is probably pushing but look
at the time keep an eye on the clock
here it's 15 seconds versus six seconds
he's going i think white's trying to go
for it yeah queen h4 the bishop's hat's
gone back
and he's okay he's he's i would say i
was about to say you have
very good sack yeah practically speaking
just just play it he should have thrown
a queen e4 check before taking on d4 i
think because he could take on d4 with
the bishop but now
his king's on h8 not the best square for
the king but allows d4 once that queen
moves out the way there's gonna be d4
with bishop d1 to go to f3
okay so that's that's a way to combat
that one but black's grabbing a lot of
pawns he's got two seconds well all
right there's right through 22 check but
there's rook f2 keep an eye on the clock
an eye on the clock clearly gets it off
can you get seven h5 for for a while
it's about queen g5 coming crazy five
you have to you have to barely gets to
move off i'm just looking at knee how's
clock and it's it's freaking me out i
mean it's okay good move for five queen
do you want this oh my gosh it looks so
rocky for blackness so rocky's just
grabbed the pawn here
so queen g1 check keep giving that king
checks queen h1 gain some time okay very
important queen g2
queen h2 to keep on h5 maybe i guess and
then uh
okay queen a1 check keep it going just
check forever
i would have blundered a queen by now
rugby it's me if you allow it can you
avoid the check so king g g4 maybe he
can avoid to check something sure if a
great move yeah now queen g5 and h5 is
falling and watch out for eight made in
h7 though
well i just follow a check so that
doesn't help
who's even better here i don't even know
better this is what i'm trying to work
out i think that white is better because
the clock
yeah yeah he's keeping the pressure on
right and he just he's got a checkmate
for it it's nice to have that fret
okay queen f to the king to b3
queen g8
oh my gosh and everything's under
control oh no
he's just watching this oh we just
checked in that passed him out wait
couldn't you be three equivalent three
queen
he got in
how did he find out so quickly oh that
was insane oh my gosh
oh
and hike just like grabs his head in
frustration wow
how do you hold that
i i have to say i'm sorry i'm so
impressed how nihal just saw that
immediately and you robert but i mean
that was just like he was playing with
one two seconds he was given one
opportunity back he took it immediately
in under a second that was incredible
he's been pushed back pushed back he's
defending trying to get a draw and as
soon as he sees an opportunity he takes
it immediately i mean okay i mean
queen b3 maybe not so hard to see but
when you've got one second all the time
and stuff he's he plays it so quick and
bishop g5 incredible i mean that was so
impressive anyhow brilliant brilliant
play from him absolutely brilliant i
mean i i you said it you would have been
checkmated like eight times over i would
have been checkmated 15 times over or
lost on the clock he didn't neither he
was giving all the checks and then still
finding like these little moves like
your bishop to f8 at the right moment
and just fending off hike and you this
is danger territory because of tilt
right you you're so upset with yourself
you're winning that game at some point
and now you're like i'm down three how
do i come back yeah
no i mean the the bullet section is
going to be incredible as we've seen
this section is incredible already but
it's time for hike to start he's got to
hike up his game a little bit
was terrible
don't make me do that again please let
me guess you commentated with dania
recently and now
how could you tell he he's the he is the
grand master of puns right oh they're so
bad they're so bad they are so bad
they're so bad they're good right
so
okay maybe just bad maybe it's just bad
let's just do that
oh man well
before not possible because bishop takes
b4 is a free pawn the rook on a1 is
hanging so king e2 i guess and then
bishop a6 okay because i mean d2 i guess
exchange of queens is solid way to play
maybe if they those guys come off you
might have some c file action hence why
black's kept them on um
normalish position but black black's
nicely developed he's got that extra
tempo right with the development
and the fret here positionally is for
black i guess to play bishop takes
bishop you don't really want to take
your f pawn i mean it's not the end of
the world but
it's it's not really ideal either well
that means that bishop takes d6 might be
forced and he does that just because of
what you were saying and bishop e2 so
white has retreated thus far and black
is in perfect position to play queen g6
or a to c8 and i'm not trying to claim
that black is better here but he's
certainly no worse
this is also a nice idea isn't it put
the knight on e4 at some stage uh nice
light squares for the white pieces
he i think he needs to get a result here
hike must get a result otherwise he's
just slipping too far behind if he goes
behind this he's going four games behind
he can come back but
you know the rot the rot is getting
worse and worse every every little
every little time and it's funny this
match because it reminds me a lot of the
part that the match that um height got
through on um against was it i can't
breath
yeah it was against parham and in that
game it was
you know it was right at the critical
moments it was always hike who was
getting better or the better sort of
edge of it in the critical moments in
this match it's knee how and nihal i
think has been playing a bit bad
positional chess as well but like that
last game critical moment he found the
move with seconds to spare
and is that just killer instinct which
is which is really strong in the house
game yeah the ability to turn defense
into offense and the snap of your
fingers is something that honestly most
people don't have yeah yeah i know it's
it's phenomenal
fairly solid here though right i mean
this this this is this is even this must
be but it doesn't mean it's a draw have
they had any draws yet i'm not sure if
there's i'm not sure oh there has
because it's half a point on the board
yeah
had they had just one draw or three
draws i don't really remember too many
draw i think just one
maybe just one yeah
yeah that that half a point gives it
away a little bit i should probably
probably look at the scores before i ask
such questions but it's um there hasn't
been many and even though this is equal
just because it's an equal position does
not mean it's going to be a draw i mean
this is something well worth remembering
again the computer addicts they say the
position is 0.00
and they think oh that's an easy draw
but then no it doesn't mean it's an easy
draw ever
well sometimes king versus king king
versus king maybe you know but yeah yeah
we'll we'll give that one a draw but
here bishop f3 e4 for example
has black over extended the pawn
structure oh and this is bishop on b7
becoming a bad piece that does happen in
plenty of end games so you have to think
about the quality of the pieces so i
would play bishop f3 and i guess there's
knight e4 potentially such as trades and
then bishop three okay this is i mean
it's
pretty level
pretty level um
[Music]
again black black pushing with h5
is is not so stupid um the one thing
about having that pawn there is a
strength is it weakness that black's got
on the e4 square
it does cramp white's king side a little
bit
a normal idea then would be to push the
h pawn but there's not enough pieces on
the board really to cause trouble to the
white king i'd say
and um
that stops knight before good move a5
yeah you'd probably need a bishop on d6
if to make you know justify any kind of
king side yeah i'm still with you though
simon i actually know that i'm looking i
do think black's position is better with
the queens in the board especially so he
plays h6 is he trying to go g5 and he
could have gone g5 without h6 he's
playing very safely isn't he i mean like
probably just a good waiting move
i mean it's a bit more space for black
to maneuver in but white is super solid
and black's pawns whoa okay that's
interesting look at that it's
sacrificing a pawn i was going to
suggest that move but i was like yeah
it's not worth it because you're giving
up a pawn but you're freeing up your
knight giving yourself the b5 the f5
square this could be
a really smart sacrifice of a pawn for
the positional edge
very clever actually very clever idea i
mean
giving that pawn up and suddenly white's
pieces have got these good squares
black's d pawn doesn't look great at the
moment but pawn is also porn let's not
forget if the queen's come off the board
then that pawn could be the telling
factor
right so white not really proving the
compensation after that for the pawn i'd
say though uh h5 now played in the time
situation neat but knee how with little
time he's been phenomenal so far
um i mean that was i mean really clever
sacrifice even if it hasn't worked out
well uh
yeah and he actually i didn't even look
at the clocks and now that i am it's
bishop h5 and 95 no there's queen e5 but
i'm looking at some kind of just
sacrificing use of this queen on the
diagonal
okay queen see there's reason but
something e5 maybe put the queen there
put the knight there i'm not sure still
it's still compensation still some
compensation
eight seconds left for nihal
that's the worst part for him so he
should just
instead of trying to play for a win at
this point just make normal moves 95 is
meant by knight b5 so you have to be
careful that's why the queen can be e5
okay going to the a7 square that's the
hope
but i think needs to try and win this
one
yeah
and he's if you can get the queens off
he'd be very happy because then the
extra pull might help at some point
um
isn't trying to get a knight c4 to work
but then pin the bishop at the end but
no it's not
i don't really like f6 so much it makes
the king feel weaker yeah and that could
tell if the the white queen comes around
the back here
but it's on the clock i mean like i'm
just looking at the clock again this is
like when it gets this situation i mean
i can't even commentate because i'm just
looking at the clock and
by the time i've got something to say
it's ten moves are gone you know right
and i mean this is critical because b5
at some point could be a good move to
take ooh nate check the king
okay there's bishop b5 check as well it
should be five don't play king d8 d6
oh my gosh bishop k8 or something knight
to b5 was a threat oh he's got in he's
got him yeah you think cringy go over
there for me how the queen has got in
he's taking things
man this guy nina's just killing it when
he's got no time look at the time he's
killing it
oh knight c6 check that's possible at
some point don't take on before
okay now you can't design a take queen
a1 queen one go all the way back
nice move oh my gosh push me too
go push me two bishop h5
it's almost made
what is happening here
that's already oh it's just insane it's
going backwards forward
oh no
so queen day you only goes queen you
just take it and take on b6 you have
many pawns for the sacrifice many queens
by the looks of it as well
it's going to be a draw queen you want
quinacridge for a back and forth is he
going to take the draw or is he going to
try to win i reckon he might try to win
this i mean so i don't know how no he
can't try to win this can he oh he does
he is he is going to try to witness i
mean hike's very confident player and i
and as you said i think you need to get
a result of this i mean a win out of
this really
he can't because i think he's closer to
a loss than oh okay yeah you're right
yesterday okay oh my gosh let's pull up
this uh on the analysis board really
quickly because there was that moment
where it went from winning for white to
winning for black and like just the move
because
where was that it was all the way down
here somewhere e3 allowed bishop d3
check and it's mate the king has nowhere
to go here here boop that's mate
and instead he went bishop to f3 and
then after queen f2 you see that the
evaluation is in black's favor because
he could have just taken his knight
instead of playing e2
yeah but i mean when you've got so so
little time
i mean it's it's really hard to play at
the level they're playing at you're
going to make blunders it's totally
impossible but bishop d3 it's always
good to look for the checks you know
that's one thing if i see a check on
that pat so we'll play it in these kind
of positions you never know it might be
mate and that was very close
it's checkmate it actually is just check
me it was yeah it would be exactly i
like that check the check oh my gosh but
it is easy for i i always say it's easy
for me to shout moves and occasionally
be right than to be in the heat of the
moment where the responsibility of that
move is on your shoulders so
what is this by the way and this is not
a very knee-haul-like position what's he
done here
i mean
you know the pawns placement like that i
mean this is this is like this just
looks a bit i mean he's going for that
kind of g5 attack we saw earlier but
he's doing a very ugly way here i mean
it might not be so bad the knight coming
to f4
it looks ugly it looks wrong it just
looks wrong to me i mean
too many light square holes there surely
and i guess you know this knight needs
to get to e3 wait so can you take on d4
i was wondering yeah why not take the
pawn take it
is he going to try to go f4 and he's
going somebody will tactical we can't i
know
i would steal that pawn for sure
yeah yeah grab the pool
ask questions later take a pawn now ask
questions later
but
do you think that hike is just super
frustrated by that last game um
i think he's been a bit frustrated at
times i mean he's still keeping his call
i think very well i mean i when i've
seen hike in other you know competitions
and earlier on this competition he seems
one of the coolest players as in he
really doesn't get affected he keeps his
call but
niihau has rocked him a bit and it might
be it might be showing now
yeah i'm just looking at the uh
the cameras of both players we also have
a fun photo of
both players throwback photos
this is the match-up you see today a
young nihal versus a young hike martial
sin and of course that's not what they
look like
today but it's a nice little throwback
to their even younger youth
yes
these guys started they started very
young
definitely their chess career when did
you start playing robot when i was about
six years old okay uh so pretty young
myself but not the three-year-old
standard that people started today i
guess what about you
about the same about six years old as
well there's the standard i think for
for most sort of uh
most a lot of players now
seem to get six for some reason i don't
know why
but i feel like i've heard stories of
people like yeah i learned chess when i
was three i was like when i was three i
didn't know anything except bothering my
parents for food i know yeah
breastfeed
[Laughter]
what don't know if is going on here
either i mean like
it's
it looks like black has a lot
okay black i mean black's still that
pouring up is there any compensation
here
i like those still the light square
control and that hasn't changed
maybe some kind of knight e4
where's that queen going what knight b4
other direction
trying to come into d5 which has a very
nice square for tonight
i mean it is i mean the white king is is
safer than the black king
um if things do open up a bit more the
black king
it's a little bit there's some weakened
squares on the e file like we're seeing
that knight come to d5 right but can i
take on c3 and sacrifice my queen like
take on c3 knight d5 i take my opinion
let's see it let's see
i want to see that queen going i'm going
i'm going full pac-man you know i just
like give up my queen and then take
yours with check and then take this
knight at the end and i have two minor
pieces and a rook for the queen that's
too much yeah the bishop on bishop on a7
is a really really nice piece wait this
is all happening oh wow okay
oh gosh always happened this has
happened this is just terrible news for
for hike yeah this is bad news i mean
black's piece has controlled everything
now
yeah very weird game this is this has to
i've been said this probably one of the
one of the worst games that hikes played
maybe it is affecting a little bit
these uh these positions he's not
converting
this is
not what he was looking for from this
opening and i mean the way that nihal
played it like i said was very unnihal
like with all these holes in his
position but i think that
went too quick he was like i need to win
this game i have a better position and i
think he lost some objectivity
yeah
this is just too many extra pieces
it should be yeah knight e4 is very
nasty you can even push the h4 with
black i love that you think about that
and it's actually a very good move but i
would never push h5 and you're like you
could just go h5 h4 go for it i'm just
thinking the bishop on g3 oh he's got
rid of it anyway i mean it's it's
clock and they're 27 and a half minutes
more or less for this portion and
when you're down pointed a match
sometimes you just have to resign and
play the next game right there's still
plenty
i guess i still play this game out there
are some chances but
i would also consider resigning
no i'm with you actually robert there
there is that gameplay element you you
want to play in until the end but
he's he's going to be four points down
at the end of this game and he's got to
give himself as much time as he can
resigning is probably one of the best
moves you can do as black here i mean
especially now i mean this is this is
just absolute onslaught now
um
he's probably gonna get perpetual check
now
and it's like oh yeah
yeah i mean there's one check on d7 this
rook can slide back so i would even
consider rookie one going against this
king
it's a rookie seven for sure
and rookie one i mean okay he's touching
it a little bit
is he gonna keen g6 and h5 push his h1
okay so is there a mate it feels like
there has to be some kind of made down
on the first rank
oh he's keeping he's keeping total
control bishop e3 total control d5 d4
he is all day if you only hope white has
is get the queen to g6 if white can
somehow
get his queen to g6 can he get stalemate
is there a stalemate somehow you know at
some point this is the other hope oh
rook h1 king g4 okay it's not checking
yeah
yeah yeah so rook h1 king g4 you give up
your queen it's stalemate like queen d4
oh right for a check ricketts where
check was there oh
oh my gosh rook h4g takes rook four oh
very nice
very nicely spotted there very nice yeah
so instead the queen remains on the
board here
oh gosh that's this is some of those
opportunities where i've just seen
enough
of these matches to just go for it i
figure out wait how do i win your queen
to simplify the position and it's very
very nicely spotted there
okay he's still winning rookie four
check g4 can be played after that if you
want
this it's amazing he hasn't finished him
off i mean hike's been very very
resilient here but the thing is if he
ends up losing this game anyway
he's he's definitely made the wrong
decision right because he's wasted even
more time
yeah this is uh
actually kind of annoying if you're
black right you're like i'm winning this
game but where's the win i know now he
has to push the d pawn which should be
enough but you still
okay that's easy he's got everything
covered now everything is covered he's
covering g6 he's covering his bishop he
just pushes the d-pawn this yeah that's
it yeah
yeah that was uh so i think i should
have it's always easy in hindsight to
say oh we should have resigned that four
minutes before but um he probably should
have
oh gosh
um yeah so i guess i have to pull this
on the screen because i see my producer
wanting me to this is me at six i don't
know if you know that i was six years
old in this photo happens to be in the
u.s championship but i was six for sure
[Laughter]
you matured very quickly
yeah i came out of the womb with a beard
simon so
bit bit like me robert yeah so
[Music]
thank you to bick for uh
pulling up that pick always fun to
you know have some jokes but what is not
a joke has been nihal sauron's play and
for hike marty rose in some if you were
his coach if you were
training him or just trying to give him
words of encouragement at this point
what do you say
well i mean it's been tough because
niihau has just been so strong i mean
knee how
is keeping he's playing a lot of
different kind of positions now as well
he's spotting tactics
and so if i was hike's trainer i'd be
like okay well look you know you're
still playing good chess as he is he's
playing good i think you need to change
the tempo a little bit um you're running
out of time in the match so
if you go at this pace you're probably
gonna you know i'm not gonna say this
that you're gonna lose the segment but
i've been saying right go a bit more
aggressive try try switching it up a
little bit just try try now not the
openings you're playing at the moment
they're not really working try something
else you must have another opening in
your arsenal give it a go so i think
that'd be my advice just go a little bit
more aggressive you're playing good
chess the score doesn't really affect
how well how how well you're playing
just go more aggressive i mean it must
be you know you've got to change
something if if you're in a bad score
right
yeah he he simply must because this is
the type of position where white
objectively is better and practically
just too easy to play so he puts his
bishop on d5 and you can bring your
knight into d6 if you'd like you can
just play e4 to kick this bishop out
how how are you gonna get results
to fix the situation you're down four
points in the match at a certain point a
draw equals a loss yeah totally because
you're just wasting time
and uh you know if you if you don't i
mean the thing with these players is
we're seeing we're seeing hype playing
pretty much the same opening time and
time again which obviously has a lot of
faith in or getting similar positions
but these players have more than one
opening nowadays they must have looked
at other openings so
why not try something else try your
other opening out give something else a
go because at one point he was getting
more favorable positions hiked than he's
really getting so just try something
different you have to you have to mix it
up uh in a match situation at this
moment it's getting to your last
opportunity and what was interesting
when jeffrey zhang played against arjun
arigasy he was saying jeffrey said that
i had played
d4 in one time segment e4 in another so
he actually had a very concerted plan of
i'm going to switch my first move
depending on how much time we begin with
and here we've seen a lot of the similar
openings and in this particular game
simon there's a knight on d4 there's a
knight on e5 bishop b2 bishop stay so
all of white's pieces are harmonious
here and black just doesn't have the
type of counter play you need to play
for not even just an advantage but just
you're having a hard time stopping
white's clear progress
yeah i mean
like you say it's a very good setup for
white because you blunted that bishop on
b7 with f3 and e4 but
it's the white knights and the white
bishop on b2 which could cause problems
and
um
this is not what you want you don't want
this position so i i would say he must
change his opening for the next game
when he's black
um
okay now queen queen f2 looks sensible
but
yeah this queen can go to g3 or to h4
depending on how
black reacts here
queen v8 is also sensible right get
trying to get rid of that night though i
mean okay black's position is not it's
not disastrous he hasn't got that many
weaknesses in in the structure but
he he's not he's got to win these
positions and he's not unbalancing the
structure enough i'd say symmetrical
structures maybe try to go for more
unsymmetrical structures when you have
to win win the game right you get more
losing chances but you get more winning
chances and i'm looking at the uh
the time by the way and uh nihal only
has 48 seconds and
his position doesn't look
that great and also what's annoying is
oh
he's falling for a trick
he's falling for tricks so black's play
after all this criticizing he his plays
now is is now turning it around so of
course this was a heist plan from the
very beginning he knew exactly what he
was doing
a master plan here no his position was
not that good but nihal he has shown
this tendency today simon where he's
wait queen takes c5 three pieces yeah
oops
he shook his head he was like wait i
didn't see my neck well probably should
play on yeah i mean there's no point
residing here because the time situation
your three games are if you're going for
pure gaming thing but i mean okay maybe
it's only a gain of 30 seconds in the
match he wants to get into the next one
that was a bad game from nihal that's
his that was his worst game so far going
from a position where he's better
really throwing it away
and he's now playing a very sharp
opening um
his three points up this is a very sharp
and tactical variation
is it wise to play is it is it wise to
suddenly go so sharp when you're when
you're leading the match oh heidi is
probably thrilled because this gives him
an opportunity to avoid just basic
symmetry and this
variation is quite complicated for
example queen takes c4 is check and it
looks like it wins your piece by taking
on f6 but the problem is i think i can
go 92 whichever move i'm not sure the
theory but the point is that once you
take on f6 i broke c1 and i win your
bishop on c8 so i think it is kg1 but
anyway the point is rook c1 and the
bishop is hanging so you can't just take
on f6 so instead we see all this
uh
other theory where there's a king on e7
simon i think that you're right nihal
probably
should play something a little more tame
but
hike is
happy to be here
yeah i mean
the this is the kind of opening you know
if you're trying to learn this at home
by the way a word of warning
you know you can learn these kind of
things but you better make sure you have
a good memory really i mean i don't
really like nowadays relying on my
memory to play a game of chess because
if you play one bad move you lose
there's other ways of playing
it it is quite a sharp position even
though now it's died down a little bit
just because the black king is in the
middle of the board
um
and when you're leading the match
okay i mean he's very confident of
playing every sort of style of playing
knee how as he's shown before so it
might not be a bad decision but it's a
different kind of way of playing that
what he's done so far
yeah and i mean the bay issue for black
is your king will never find true
shelter if you trade the queens off well
then your king is great it's in the
center but white is not training the
queens both because of the match
situation and what's going on on the
board and the queen on d3 bishop c4 rook
c1 all these pieces even the knight on
b3 they're all working together quite
well black's rook a8 bishop c8 not in
the game quite yet so black is up a pawn
but is delayed in development
yes i and again
it might be all right for black this
position but it's practically speaking
practically speaking
it's very hard for black to play it's
quite easy for white to play white can
just keep the pressure on black's
position
but if your kings in this structure you
make one mistake you lose so it's sort
of practically speaking harder for black
um pointing out some good ideas there
robert white seems it seems to be a good
idea to try and get the rook to d1
certainly in such a structure
although i do wonder now that i made the
suggestion if there's like a queen h2
that i have to keep an eye on because
queen e6 it defends off the diagonal
from any checks but it also can give
that queen the h2 square which could be
quite annoying
yes i mean
if nihal can get bishop d7 as well and
just get his rook somewhere he's
improving his position so
this is preparing to meet bishop d7 with
knight c5
and so he's he's trying to stop this
developing movement
will he what he's got to play knight c5
now on the auction so he gives up the b7
pawn because
there's queen
gotta be careful queen a freeze haven't
you
queen a freeze okay so he's getting the
queens off he's just saying right i
don't want to defend this position have
the pawn back get the queens off this is
my safest way this is actually very
clever
black was a pawn up when you're
defending if you can just give your pawn
back to liquidate the position so you're
safe it's often the best technique in
the position and and i think it's worked
seems to be working okay here and
there's no choice for hike because he
would like to keep the queens on the
board and go after the q87 but queen d3
is the only way to protect the bishop
but after queen e3 is knight e5 hitting
the queen protecting the bishop
threatening your bishop on b5
threatening your rook on c1 i think you
can get the point there's too many
pieces under attack and black's just
completely winning
yes so
okay well he's he's the queens are
coming off but
maybe black has some other options now
possibly
like
probably not actually yeah i think that
queen takes e4 but i'm worried about
your queen a3 idea at some point the
king is not very good in the center
but maybe i can i don't know can i get
away with it
i've got queen c5 i can try it out
queens e5 is crushing yeah i was looking
at queen a3 but not the better and more
forward option okay
okay so more exchanges being made here
can anyone claim an advantage in this
position well you did say earlier on the
one good thing about black's position is
his king right and uh if the queen's
come off black has the king in the
middle of the board and he does have the
king on the middle board so
with that b pawn now being very weak
it's uh
bishop d said how did you just stop
bishop d7 next move
is it maybe black's just winning this
you still play well this is the wrong
pawn right the corner does not match the
bishop right so you look at the a1
square and the bishop on d7 they don't
match if white can trade all of the king
side pawns then the game will be a draw
even without this knight and a5 so
that's how i think about these positions
that's one big if though there's a lot
of pawns to get off yeah it's gotta
but you know it it should be a technical
windows because the other thing you've
got to remember about a knight
a knight is the worst piece for
defending a pawn on the side of the
board an a or an h pawn because it can't
jump off the board to get to the other
side you know you can only stay sort of
half on the side of it it's better
defending a pawn in the middle of the
ball because it can use both sides to
stop that pawn from coming forwards and
i i hope you like my sign language there
the knight jumping around there i
thought it was excellent simon and you
know you're if this bishop could get to
d5 the game would just be over because
the knight is trapped and that's your
whole point the knight in the side of
the board has just huge limitations
yeah so i mean you can try going f5 for
that reason then you know if you want to
i mean
position yeah he's played it honestly he
takes can you play bishop d5 very i mean
it okay it's
he's gone for the more safer approach
now knight now bishop d5 surely this is
total domination now total domination
ned strand
game over
that's really nice i mean that bishop
dominating that knight is that pattern
and one of those patterns in chess which
as soon as you see it as soon as you
remember it your game will improve
instantly um
as is the case here
yeah and i always say this when i
commentate a pawn three squares away
from a knight dominates it a bishop
three squares away for night just i mean
takes all of its squares away and here
we go you'll see yeah just king b5 or
you're pushing the part first you go a3
use that positive decoy and bring his
king to the king side he's just yeah he
got this one
yeah the outside pass pawn it is is
nearly always winning the extra outside
passport in a kingdom pawn ending i
think you can see now hike's body
language dropped down a little bit as
well he hasn't got the same energy he
had at the start of the match
understandably
nihal now mixing up the opening even
more here
with e3 okay we're back back into normal
positions time they've got 12 minutes
left robert
does hike have any chance
i think he needs with these final 12
minutes he needs to get a couple
victories to end the time until
otherwise nihal's bulletproofs will be
seen but before we see anything else i
have to bring our attention
to a younger simon williams
how old were you here don't tell anybody
yet i want to guess i want to guess okay
how old was i here um
i um you know what i i i can guess how
old i was there i had a non-bearded sign
with him so i'm 40 years old now and uh
i can yeah i mean wow
the innocent look at my face
were you like 17 there
younger
i think i might be like about i don't
know i i don't even know how old it was
that's the problem i had no idea i'm
guessing i was probably 17 or 18 yeah i
think i was
well we'll have to get confirmation of
that i have no idea where our producer
pulled that photo from no i don't know
i'd like to know how old i was i don't
know
the years have been rough
i personally like the beer i think it's
a great look for you so uh
you babyface simon from back in the day
has nothing on you know bearded babies
debated
[Laughter]
and all simon we did say we didn't think
that hike should play this again he is
playing this line once more and
nihal
shouldn't be too fearful of what's to
come in this game
yeah i mean it's it's he did win that
game when we said he should be doing it
but
the positions he's getting on you know
how like we say 10 minutes left
they just don't seem unbalanced enough
the one good thing about this opening i
suppose
black does keep all the pieces on the
board for a long time and that keeps a
lot more tension than other openings
where maybe they get exchanged off
quickly it's just the pawn structure i i
i don't really think is a good way to go
for a win
yeah and
you know you look at the pieces and
which pieces are better the rooks are
connected for white and blacks work on
f8 not in the game just yet and often
white tries to take advantage of that
fact you can play b4 i wouldn't do that
because it gives the a4 square but you
can play b4 to kick this knight on c5
whereas the knight d4 is stable where it
is this knight can jump into e5 quite
easily the bishop on b1 stares at the
king side as is the fisherman b2 so i
just feel like
many of white's pieces are better placed
than blacks and that's why it should be
a slight advantage yeah
nicely pointed out though
um
not easy to use that advantage to to
create something as we've seen but he's
put his knights in the same
same structure as we saw in the last
game this knight on e5 knight on on d4
but
black
playing quite solidly in the position as
well now he has managed to connect the
rook so
it's it's probably okay for black i
thought that he could have gone knight
to g4 instead of knight d4 to f3 like if
we just go back and move knight to g4
like i want to start trading stuff to
get after your king with my pieces and
i don't think it really should work but
the threat is often stronger than the
execution
yeah it looks scary that one get rid of
the one defender the knight on f6 and
just go for the kill
their style of chess it is quite
it's quite i suppose um
patient
um throughout the match they've both
been showing a great deal of like you
know preparing
preparation not rushing into any king
side attack we haven't seen really any
outrageous attacks against eva king they
you know it happens much later on the
game they've been building maneuvering
it's very mature you know you say that
younger players
in the past when you know certainly they
were supposed to be more tactical and
not as mature but these two have shown a
great deal of maturity uh in their play
they certainly are they're showing
restraint which is very difficult uh for
a lot of younger players not just
younger players i mean i feel the same
way yeah yeah but
i feel like
it's either one or the other you show
too much restraint and really you're
hesitant and you're not actually
striking when the moment's right or
you're just going full steam ahead
trying to sacrifice even when the
position doesn't call for it whereas it
does feel like nihal has been
particularly measured today he um has
had moments where he's gone for it i
think he's a little bit still showing
too much restraint but he has been more
balanced i would say than hike has
yes yeah he is
he has shown and also his speed right at
the end but he's got two or three
seconds left
has been phenomenal which is a very good
sign for him going into the bullet
section
um okay well
he's he's now got this uh this obviously
clear advantage in the position by
taking on h7 at the same time
queen b2 only move but isn't
black's position really creaking here
yeah holding on by a thread and
well what move to play for white roxy
too it's pretty simple
rook c2 looks like the oh wait my game
needed your king oh yeah
rook c2 is it's
i didn't see that either i didn't hurt
me brook c2 and it and it's mate but
okay
hide me no don't look at me i blundered
checkmate
whoa queen h4 check throwing in a check
before taking this bishop she's just
showing off
um
oh man
it's quite hard comet i mean it's hard
playing in this probably harder playing
but commentating and keeping up the
ideas
the amount of bla mates i've blundered
and queen queen things is in the
thousands during commentary by now
yeah you know forgetting that the bishop
on d6 covers the only escape square
we all make that mistake it's happened
to the best of us but definitely
definitely okay so the rook and d8 is
hanging so
and then he wanted to go to g8 but he
never had the opportunity to is it now
knight c6 is
no okay you got bishop f8 always
something you say
okay so bishop f8 blocks and
is black trying to play e5 and win this
b3 pawn and say hey my queenside pawns
are too strong for you
it's really weird it feels to me that
black's play shouldn't work but
he's kind of making it work somehow i
mean with a you know putting your king
on back on his start square your bishop
next to it is he going to try to put the
rook in the corner and the queen i mean
it shouldn't work but
he's keeping his at least he's keeping
that defensive position but now this is
clever swinging the queen over to the
other side of the board it looks like a
good idea boat look at the time though
if if
hake well if he loses this one hike
sorry uh it's i think it's gonna be too
much again as king's on e7 that's not
good he's stopping knight at five so you
can play e5 if he wants to
king back to the eight so maybe
i mean i feel like white should have
something here it just looks like a
position where white should be better
so get your knight around to the light
square
and i think also in this situation white
should be the one playing on even if
he's not better black is in more
dangerous in some check just the king
safety and queen g8 but the queen of b3
protects very importantly the f7 square
so maybe rook c1 will i know the queen's
the rooks will come off then
so
now looks good
okay
look at the speed though they're going
this is where this is where in the past
knee how is sean you know neha has
really shown
that when he gets to that you know and
is he going to do it again he's causing
problems he's causing a lot of problems
rook d1 this is the the piece is
starting to coordinate yeah queen d5 as
possible he was rookie fighter queen d3
and rookie czech that's his new idea um
i don't think we d3 as well and like
yeah there's lots of ideas here so
rookie
king hasn't she said 97 check g7 still
so he gave himself some space and maybe
it's black with that opponent b4 who can
turn this one around
very clever what black did there getting
the king to g7 i mean that king was the
one problem that black had but
now he's got queen d1 is he gonna be
able to get it in get some play queen
five seconds left bishop six and there's
one can't stop it he's got mate
oh my god gosh wouldn't
he's gonna he's gonna win it what an
important win that was
well done to hike right yeah let's look
at that really quickly because that was
just
something crazy there where it felt like
nissan was pushing
did you know how old i was in that
picture by the way uh we just got our
producer telling us
unbelievable you know that that picture
of me which you just saw apparently i
was 24. i thought i was 17. i was 24
years old yes they were no you weren't i
think i might have been i was quite
baby-faced and and and fairly
fairly fairly uh healthy chap
and then and then and then you know
they didn't even repair shops
pear-shaped wow i guess uh with quindy
one that only was queen of b3 in that
position to stop it and white is up a
pawn for the time being but he goes
forward thinking that he gets this
check-in but it's only one check after
queen d1 he takes on e5 and loses the
game and i guess knight h2 is the only
move to survive but who's playing that
with no time in your clocks let's get to
the uh current game i still can't
believe that you were 24 there's
something i mean
yeah i mean getting served in the bars
was always a bit of a problem that's why
that's why i had to grow the beards you
know just so i could get a beer
um
well that was an important win i mean
how we got this is the last game of this
segment and if hike
can get this one get this one under his
belt then there's only two games in it
in the bullet which is which is really
doable right
yeah uh for sure and
these type of positions i like from
white's point of view hike has a spatial
edge with the white pieces you just play
c4 claim some more space and say hey man
what are you going to do with your
knights they're just not getting active
for black and d4 you can put your knight
into d5 please take me i'll take with my
e pawn i really would not like to have
nihal's position
yeah this is getting very close this
match and very important last win
as you say white's position to be
preferred here
knight g6 there's a lot of ways you can
play this you can even start throwing a
rook just simply to a7
maybe you can go rook d1 i mean he's
gone rook d1 centralizing i don't like
the choice of rook though
because the e4 pawn is already defended
so i would have put the e-rook on d1 and
left my rook over on a1 in the open file
okay white still must be better though
white has this extra space he can push
with and that's a nice move i like that
g3 just stopping black's knight diving
into the position
very i just think this is a really
important game robert don't you because
just from a psychological point of view
if hike wins this he's got two games in
the bullet section that is very doable
he's still doable even if he doesn't win
but you know he's going to throw nihal
off kilter a little bit when the break
occurs as well and i think the break
actually would come at a perfect time
for both players if nihal does lose this
game it will just give him time to take
a breath to relax say you know i've lost
two games in a row that's not good but i
still have a two-game lead and for hike
although he would have what you would
think of as the momentum the play itself
has been shaky at times so he can get
his you know mind ready for the bullet
portion when really that's just
anybody's chance because the bullet is
just hectic it's chaos and uh he is just
as good of a chance well i won't say
that nihal is the better bullet player
but hike is an amazing bullet player
himself
yeah
so i think knee how's now going to try
to go for well exchanges if he can
because white's pieces are better but
it's a space advantage which is a
problem for black because the other
thing is if if white ever plays b6 or c6
and then
then white can just try to win that
remaining pawn and his pawns are so near
queening in in end game positions
um
is also his knights are better right
robert because the knight on e3 has more
potential that knight on g6
is a really bad piece um yes
it's it's not good nowhere to go with
that knight and it has to stay here to
help protect the e5 pawn so it's a
defensive knight and it can't jump
anywhere look at this knight d5 taking
advantage of the extra space and if i
can move your knight away from f6 then i
can play h5 and win your e5 pawn very
directly
yes it's just i mean if you take on d5 i
can even take with the e pawn and now i
have three of these pawns in the fifth
rank pushing four i just wonder if you
should try that in queen f5 or something
i mean like
maybe he has to take the knight here i
don't see many other options
sense from your voice you're like i
don't really want to do that but i i
don't want to do it because like you say
he takes
if you're not falling into some tactics
it's just going to be very strong i mean
queen f5 is the only
thing to cause problems okay he's gone
rook takes rook takes controls the
position i guess better
yeah and h5 still a threat knight
getting kicked the e5 pawn is under
attack already and he'll take with the
queen on d5 and keep that queen stuck on
c8 so maybe this was the
better choice i would have been too
tempted to take with the pawn though and
look at the time look at the time two
minutes versus 20 seconds
this is this has to be one if white does
not win this one
it's i mean it
there's some kind of knight of four at
some point because you can't take it but
i guess it doesn't quite f6
that's a good move very necessary
yeah now knight h4 has to be played
come here
that looks
pretty dangerous nine to five coming so
he drops the queen back and it's funny
you don't want to trade queens as white
but there are times where trading queens
actually still works out for you yeah
i guess keep the queen as active as you
can maybe just queen b8 here looks queen
d1 checking take on h5
oh
so he has to watch out for that quindy
one check is going to be an option and
actually every queen d won oh and he
doesn't have any more if the king went
to g quinty one for sure
like when you won
and then you choose this knight at four
check
aha knight f4 after king g2 because
you've queen
there's black turning this around yes
okay knight f5 knight f4 right
yep this is knee house
he's done it he's got the knight in and
he can actually take on h5 with the
queen because the knight is immune from
capture on f4
but he'll probably make the draw but
queen h5 says you can't take on
my knight
i mean the the clock i mean the thing
that i found with this is
it it's in that game that was okay oh
the timer's up there i don't know if
this game's gonna count but i i i don't
know what the ruling is okay it's
aborted but the the this has happened a
couple of times but in that position
hike was doing very well in the position
uh he was clearly like had a nice
advantage and he had a two-minute
advantage but then knee how this has
been the thing nihal when he's had
seconds left has played amazing so i'm i
the way it's going his bullet section
i'd be a little bit scared if i was on
team hike at the moment because he's
already played bullet chess and a lot of
these games have done well
it's true i mean i'm looking at the
clock two minutes for hike 12 seconds
for nihal and in this position you want
to flag your opponent yes but when you
have the advantage and your opponent is
nearing uh flagging territory i mean
like queen b8 objectively is probably
better than queen c7 because you're
pinning the knight but you just need to
be as
just difficult as possible and credit to
nihal for
great defense here bringing the night
out bringing the queen in and he did
everything right you couldn't ask for
more he probably if he had more time
could you go queen takes h5 and play for
a win or queen h3 and say you know you
can't take my knight without losing
yours but he did the smart thing with
6.9 seconds left
yep
oh
well simon i mean before we go to break
let me ask you three game lead for nihal
does hike have a chance or did him not
winning that game really just relinquish
all opportunity
he's definitely got a chance i mean
don't don't rule him out the way things
are going
obviously niihau is strong favorite not
just because he's three games up but
when he's got shorter time he's playing
brilliantly but if height can just
switch up a gear he's a brilliant bullet
player anyway and get a bit of a roll
going of course he can come back bullet
chest there's half an hour to go it's
still open i feel
i'm with you there partner and well we
will see the final 30 minutes of this
match in the bullet when we return from
this break and there's more junior
speeches championship action brought to
you by chess.com and chesskid.com
[Music]
so
and we are getting set for the bullet
portion of this junior speed chess
championship match and just because this
match should be over pretty soon does
not mean that the fun stops here at
chess.com after this there will be the
speed chess championship super swiss
knockout today is october 4th you see on
the graphic here 12 p.m pacific time
that's 3 p.m eastern
you know i don't know what it is in
europe you can see central european
standard time there but uh it's going to
be a lot of fun but the top 16 players
taking part in what is kind of an sec
mini format with a knockout bracket
yeah loads of good chess today
as always on chess.com um and this is
this is the exciting segment right
robert i mean uh they're they're ready
to roll pretty much and uh can can he do
it can he come back knee how been
playing so well now but it's a one
minute segment you can win a load of
game in a load of games quickly right
you certainly can in neolis he's such a
great bullet player hike is as well but
throughout the match we've seen nihal
play the better chess between the two
but bullet is just anybody's game it's
hectic
there are so many blunders that will be
made but there also will be some very
good moves especially with that one
second increment
yes so it's half an hour one minute plus
one and they are off so they've gotta
speed up both of them now looks like
they're gonna repeat the same opening
with b6 right
surprise surprise simon yeah yeah i know
and
you know this has actually i mean we say
that hake hayek should have changed this
but he's won the last two games he's had
in this even those positions haven't
really been that impressive
um
so
he needs to start strong i think if he
gets a win in the first game or two he
can start the role going and that's his
chance it's three points in it the games
go quickly
was there a tactic just missed your
bishop e4 what up bishop takes h7 queen
d3 queen takes d7 we talked about this
earlier yeah yeah i mean that that that
looks like it wins the pawn right so he
missed that tactic
but it is interesting because nihal
played knight e5 rather than knight g5
so he's the one who switched the
variation first
and maybe he has done a bit of prep here
because this position
is looking a little bit shady isn't it
for for black i don't know a little bit
no it certainly is because bishop h4
bishop h4 oh gosh that's a cruncher
oh
that's just killing that is absolutely
killing because you got you got oh it's
just that it's just a killer that's game
over i think game over it must be yeah
rook d6 now you can put more pressure on
this knight and just put queen f3 yeah i
think there's rook b6 here the only way
to defend but this is not the
configuration of pieces you want from
black swords this is horrible right i
mean you've nearly got d7s but you don't
need you don't need to go that far of
this position but
i mean black's pieces are all over the
place here queen g457 you're right yeah
you have got root d7 coming
i mean also just knight g3 to f5 is is a
simple way to do but put the rook on
these win the piece game over
boom bad start there for hike bad bad
start do you see nihal's rating by the
way 32 94.
is that even a real number i i don't i
don't know i mean that's that's
that's stupidly high what kind of rating
is that i mean come on man oh my gosh
oh i didn't realize it was that high i
mean okay
sorry sorry hike
you know
you're a good player but that is that's
phenomenal right at this point stockfish
doesn't even have a chance against nihal
and in bullet because in stockfish
supposed to be like 3300 and komodo and
all those engines
oh so i mean yeah hike is really up
against it but he he um
you know
he needs to do something he needs to do
something and he it does seem
okay knee held very solid here still
yeah no weaknesses are such
yeah now this rook come to d7 go after
the d2 pawn the dark squares in front of
the
king over here knight d5 and force the
bishop off the board if you want to make
that trade
this doesn't look good knight g4 can
come yeah and you can start pushing your
a pawn as well as black just to cause a
little bit of probing you know i love
pushing those weak pawns it's a great
move it really is whoa
oh he's just getting flashed now he's
showing us why he's like three thousand
five hundred million waiting
well that is just that's just showing
off and it's a good move it's a great
move because the pawn the ether is
pinned and now you just uh undoubled
your pawns and will cause a weak pawn
for white in the process simple way to
play simple and good
you tell it so quickly
yeah
yeah so hike is really up against it um
at the moment being down
on the score as well has he got any hope
of coming back and
he's gonna have to play the best chess
of his life to to have any any chance
here he's fighting hard though now he's
got his rook coming around the back it's
it's potential chances you mean you got
queenie fives against that but
i don't think you're going anywhere the
king comes to a6 but yeah
at least that rook's got active
he's he's done something good there yeah
he could not just sit passively and
defend he had a6 which
that looks strange and rook h7 played
with her muscles aren't going to queen
at 4. threatens both queen for
threatening both f7 and brook h8
checkmate
okay so how'd you defend against this
because rook rook check and queen b8
looks scary can you just take that ball
and not not be scared
bring the king can you do that bring the
king to b6
i like it i like it simon just take on
d3
show off here show no fit if it works it
works yeah so
yeah and he thinks it works and if it
does work it'll be another another point
for nihal this is this could be knee
hell hour it really could ah
i just you're right rook h8 looks scary
but it's just a check king c7 queen b8
looks scary as well but can be six
there's no more checks
okay this is the best you can do but
yeah you're not actually
threatening all that much here
no i mean black can always swap queens
but he probably shouldn't do that at the
moment because c5 and yep queen c5 check
actually another option here so rook h4
would be a blunder trying to pin the
rook as queen c5 check
makes the pin disappear yeah but queen
f5 you can win the rook but you lose
your rook on d4 yeah
so queen c5 still looks like a good
option okay is he gonna okay now he's
played c5
very tough position for white here queen
f6 was uh was good
still could be coming though yeah
rotates b3 check oh queen d4 this could
be even better just the centralization
with new house pieces is incredible here
i mean they're just dominating the board
and two seconds to hike as well
um
it's another one it's another point i
don't see height coming back from this
now knee how's just playing too well at
the moment he's got to change this
opening don't play this opening hike
what wheel out the dutch why aren't you
playing the dutch and simon i'm
surprised but niel isn't even the top
bullet player on the site uh i guess i
should never be surprised when he
carries at the top of things but hikaru
for ruja grishouk didn't expect that and
then that's on draken fairches on
youtube and then finally nihal
okay so top five in the world still
pretty pretty handy isn't it yeah
only only top five was an underachiever
no yeah he's got time he's still got
he's still got a couple of years on his
side he also sells a couple games on the
side because if he keeps winning he'll
uh surpass andreikin in fourth i mean
again the opening robert here has just
gone knee how's way right i mean he's
he's won a pawn he's got hold of e5
black's getting a bit desperate with
some brook swinger i think that rook f6
was a it seems more desperation than
anything else and i i mean you i think
he's it's two i think it's too late now
but i caught he can't play this opening
anymore you just no no and i mean this
rook h6 is just there's knight enough
three bishops you're not attacking
anything but this was already you know
way past the point of return because the
opening has not gone his way all match
and we've said this time and time again
so for nihal getting comfortable bullets
his specialty in addition to being an
amazing bliss player
nothing that
i can do
no i mean it's a bit depressing when
you're in this situation and you're uh
you know you're facing you're facing
someone so strong you know you're a good
player and hike
is an amazing player but niihau
is just ruthless absolutely ruthless
and i'm looking at the match like 22
minutes up so actually if hike can win
this game
and start a winning streak then he has a
chance but he's not winning this game
yeah he needs to get he needs a miracle
really um
white's a very strong sea pawn up and
black's you know quite courageous
throwing all those pieces at white's
king
but everything is defended everything is
defended at whites everything
too many pieces for white over there and
the c-pawn can start running uh very
quickly
wait rook h5
okay that wasn't the best that gets a
little bit that makes it a little bit
more complex and down goes you know me
five and you're only 15 seconds left wow
oh
okay i like that i really like that
knight g4 h3 that knight is pinned over
here
he's found the only way out of it and uh
but now hike's got a chance right
because queen queen is
nice mcqueen
but it's nice having the cpanel isn't it
i'd still rather be white don't get me
wrong but i mean it's better than it was
he's got a chance now
maybe a ver the slimmest of slim chances
yeah not very not very big chance like
you can even play c6 here actually just
push that pawn through he does it and he
has
he's played it with 5.6 seconds left
more than enough time with the increment
for him to push that's so quick he's so
quick isn't he queen e4 doesn't achieve
anything because f3 just blocking out
the one fret towards g2
and um he has to try bishop b7 but
there's some something nasty could occur
there with a king getting mated somehow
right
bishop h4
in that position rook c5 oh yeah i okay
so he's going for this way
you want to play rook b1 but do not
blunder your rook on that square i
almost did um so queen e4 f3 you saw
this afternoon and bishop f2 to block a
check everything defended
where's the checkmate how do i actually
deliver the knockout
i hear you help me it's getting close
yeah there's the checkmate
ender game he does it again he's just
he's just crushing it isn't he i mean
he's literally just a monster at this
absolute monster he's free over 3 300
now
insane absolutely insane i count can't
count nearly that high but he
did pass on draken for number four on in
bullet on chess.com so what a beast what
an absolute monster
and by the way this opening also isn't
going to get like bishop hanging
on reigns of course i mean yeah
i think he's just gone yeah this is and
you can see you can see his body
language now i mean this this is the
problem when someone's playing so well
against you even if you can compete with
them which i know height could on a good
day
it you know you start losing you know
the match is probably over it's it's
just tilt it's that poker term tilt
isn't it which which can occur and
how long we got of this left 20 minutes
can and and knee has won every game
right every day yes
he has and you know we had the dancing
heads on uh stream here showing what the
odds were looking like and of course
nihils
heavily favored and now at this point
he's
pretty much locked the match up unless
he loses all the rest of the games not
gonna happen i mean even then you can
time out a little bit can't you you
could do a little bit of gameplay and
just wait and spend a bit of time and
just like you know there's too many
points in it now too many points
um such a big gap
and i mean look what he's doing here
with the white piece in this game he's
got a better position a better pawn
structure and
oh gosh h4 h5 kicking this knight making
use of this bishop on b2
one thing i've been really impressed
with robert is i i like i mentioned it
was only maybe two three i know years
ago probably three years ago where i
played this tournament in iceland which
was um a very small tournament and i was
sharing this place with nihao and there
was only about five grand masters
playing um
and niihau at that time he was strong
don't get me wrong we were sharing a
place we look we looked at a lot of
chess together but he was only like 2500
i say only he was only 2500 strong which
is great for his age but the amount he's
improved clearly in that quite small
space of time
is phenomenal he was really talented he
was really really nice kid by the way as
well very humble
very very inquisitive but the amount
he's improved in those three years and
you can just see it i can see the
difference it's just there glowing in
his the way he's playing these positions
it's phenomenal and i don't know if he
has a coach if he does his coach is
doing a great job who is his coach you
know he should be here he must have a
coach right i'm positive he does and um
i think it could be narayanan i'm not
positive on that i don't want to give
somebody else credit uh where it may not
do but i think it is and i mean what
you're saying is completely true simon
and for some of these players
ratings don't tell the whole story
because they have some untapped rating
gains and i feel like that's where nihal
is right now he's 26 20 or so and he's
feels like he's playing even better than
that these days
i i totally agree i mean um he's he's
he's improving and his improvement a lot
of people a lot of especially when
you're junior you haven't got to your
maximum you improve you improve but
suddenly you plateau and you might even
go down a little bit but nihal seems to
be still on that rise upwards i mean
just the fact i think even carlson
magnus carlsen approached nihal to be
one of his seconds
um and i've heard something like that i
don't know if that's true i could be
making it up but i think just the fact
that carlson has this respect for him
shows and you know this is carlson he
knows how chess has played obviously and
just that fact just shows how good knee
how is and how much he's improving but
he's he's he puts the work in at the end
of the day even if you're very talented
it is about the work he's going to win
another one here he's not sure much so
easily it's the work it's the coaching
it's everything and he's he seems to
have the magic formula at the moment
it's it's amazing i did not know that
actually though that's a really
interesting tip
i think i might be right robert i i
could have just made that up of course
but
i think i heard something like that yeah
i think it's very plausible because i've
heard from some juniors about um elite
players asking them to work at seconds i
you know if i could say i would
specifically say who but i have you know
confirmation of that and so it's not
that surprising to hear because
they may be young they may not have the
experience of the other top players but
they have ideas they have hunger and
they're always searching for plans and
you hear somebody like daniel dubov
who's not as young as the participants
in the junior speeches championship but
he is renowned for his creativity any
opening it may be the driest of dry
openings he still is coming up with the
unique idea here and there and that's
why people
seek his advice in particular magnus
carlsen
yeah that's totally true and i i wonder
how long it's going to be until nihal is
facing off against magnus in a serious
sense of the of the words i mean even
here his position looked kind of worse
and he's just turned it around again i
mean he he he was a bit worse i think me
how obviously hike is
very he's going to be very depressed now
probably wants the match to be over but
he's just relentless absolutely
relentless he's won every game in the
segment every single game
unbelievable wow and there's no wonder
now why nihal was the uh primitive
favorite to win the junior speed chess
championship not only is he an amazing
blitz player but he is an otherworldly
talent in bullets so no matter who he
will face in the finals whether it's
jeffrey zhang or alexi saranac they have
their work clearly cut out for them and
if i am jeffrey if i'm alexi what i'm
doing is playing a lot of bullet in the
near future to get myself ready
yeah yeah i mean that's that's the thing
you know you're going to be up against
it um in the bullet section against
niihau
there's no doubt about that and the
other segments as well
not just the bullet um
will he i mean bick is asking our
producer who's
the best the best pick in the world
there's not many bicks around so that's
why he's the best but yeah he's asking
will this be adoption will it will he
actually
i mean i don't really want to see
adoption that's a bit cruel at this
stage but is he going to win every game
in this section
uh quincy five cover g6 so the answer is
yes that he is winning this game as well
he's not gonna win every game he's
halfway through he's won every game what
odds would you say on him uh totally
adopting
well it's just crazy because hike marty
rosen might blank me if we played bullet
in this time patrol right he's 3040
himself that is
no slouch that is a superstar bullet
player in his own right and nihal's just
making it look easy and of course part
of it is the match history like you're
playing you know you're looking at the
match score if you started with a blank
slate it could be a bit different but i
mean nihal is just i think he's yeah i
think he's gonna win every game
there's a good chance how can you stop
him
i mean uh
it's
it's horrible you know just to stop him
on this run and
again this is a better position and also
hike realizes he doesn't really want to
be playing now you know he uh he's he's
had enough okay well there's a glimmer
here for hike hikers won a pawn maybe no
adoption anymore he's done a little
tactic he's grabbed the pawn this this
is a pawn up for hike he's just got to
convert it he's not the rod he has to
watch out for f4 f5 that's like the one
idea that i'm looking at and
what just happened here he gave back a
pawn
but there's too many tactics honestly my
my head can't handle wait wait no i'm
totally the same
i'm too slow these guys are too quick i
can't even get involved with the chest
at the moment it's too much for me well
that's still an extra pawn fry so he
gave up his uh queenside pawn for that
central pawn and here's the knight of g4
bishop e5 is a threat so watch out for
that he brings his knife back to f5 for
that reason very good square for the
night uh defending defending those
things though okay i don't think he's
gonna lose this game
well
i mean he's so far hike's played
brilliantly in this game
yes oh nice move rook takes d4 has
returned wins the bishop on c4 two
pieces under attack that's a win for ike
yep
and you can see you can see nihal
shaking his head there so even when he
loses one game
this is kind of another side of a
champion they do want to win every game
you know is he gonna maybe he's gonna
time out here just to be safe is this
like a bit of gameplay
okay he's trying some some bizarre
tactic here uh yeah i was looking at the
match clock 12 minutes just over there's
no reason for oh look at this cheeky
tactic this is this is just this is just
like you know
oh gosh that was too much knight g3
check no because they're nice protecting
d1 i was looking at for a cool sacrifice
f3 oh
everything's losing and now g3 check
after that
but again you might as well draw the
game out just in case
every every 30 seconds you save you get
nearer to victory
very true
and we'll see some trades here an extra
piece for black
but using the time just
running the match clock no reason not to
why not
clever game play you know it's it is a
sport i mean some people say oh he
shouldn't do this but he's going to win
anyway and he's just uh he's just doing
it in the
in the most professional way i suppose
the right word i'd like to see knight
and bishop versus king
i don't think there's much much of a
chance of that but you know
i would like to see that
that would be something
yeah it's not going to happen there's
too many pawns there
how many times oh you can win one you
can win
you won one of them all so if you can
win the other one
come on just got to take the other pawn
it's knight and bishop versus king
how many times have you had that end
game in your career never i've never had
it i don't not not not in a real game
i've never had never had it in a feed a
raider game i think i can't i can't
remember having it so he's probably good
because i probably wouldn't win it
you know how in american tournaments
there sometimes there's no increment
so i i played in some tournament without
increment and i was really in huge time
trouble but i had night in bishop it was
a rapid tournament and i'm down to the
wire playing with an analog clock you
know with the little flag going up and i
did win the game within the allotment
because um my coach he drilled it into
me like he was like this is how you do
it the m the w however you want to look
at it this is the pattern and i did it
super quickly and people were like well
how did you do that i was like
you know practice
wiping the dirt off the shoulders
brushing it off
[Laughter]
but it looks good when you do it right
oh yeah yeah i mean again chess people
think these guys are magicians and they
are but people will remember the amount
of hours both myself and robert and the
players here have put him behind the
scenes and
you can't you can't get good at chess
until you unless you really practice i
mean it you know it's like anything in
life you gotta you've got to put the
hours in if you want to if you want to
achieve
certainly um and there are certain
theoretical end games that you just need
to know because you you really don't
know when it will come up for example
simon you said you've never had it in
the feta ready game but if you did come
up you would
fully know how to
get the checkmate which is important and
yeah
there's so many different end games out
there and it is important to study your
theory and this game is not an endgame
just yet and look at this h5 move and
this is something we've talked about
many times is that you know if your
opponent is working on the queen side
there are times you just push your pawns
over there on the king side
yes and h4 is a bit of annoying threat
here um at the moment
so he dropped the bishop back to e2 and
well simon something else i'm noticing
look at nihal's rating he's sad probably
oh that's why he was sad because it's
gone below 20 to 3 300. i was going to
say 2000 something but i just remembered
how high they were
i mean have you been over three thousand
roberts i know you're an awesome blitz
player as well i mean uh
phenomenally quick i mean i i can only
dream of that 3 000 number no no i mean
that number is reserved for really just
the you know elite of the elite yeah
upper echelon of blitz down my high is
something like 29.50 and i was very
proud to get that high yeah
quickly went down to i think i'm in like
20 50 territory now so ah
you know fine it's good but it's not
these guys
i think on i the original icc i got over
3 000 but that was that was different
different days
[Laughter]
yeah i mean i don't know if neha was
born when you did that no it's like when
i was over 3000 he probably wasn't
around even
what do we think of this ending this is
quite a peculiar one i mean i i would
say white i mean it's probably a draw
but if anything i'd probably take white
here uh i guess well now i'm definitely
taking white because uh these pawns are
in some danger here yeah cleveland
you wouldn't you actually went up on my
force b5 knight c7 so he goes bishop d7
giving up this pawn is a knight trap
though
you go b3 can't you but then you might
not be able to win right so right if i
take you on yeah
it's not so easy to win this so then i
can go to c8 as well he starts there
yeah but where's it going next
yeah
you've got to be careful of knight a7
bishop d7 but then b4 it's a weird
position weird position so plays a4 he's
just trying to trap the knight yeah
actually
he can't win this if knee how wins this
ending as well that would just be cruel
yeah
stop it knee how stop it
how does this knight get out though
not easily
wait i actually don't think it does
i like that
oh but you can't go qd7 because there's
knight a7 so you actually have the king
d8
and then knight wait where's the knight
going though it's still stuck he's
trying to triangulate oh to f7 so it's
just drop oh my gosh
weird draw
yeah you don't see a repetition like
that oh okay he's
he's he had to do this yeah because he's
losing the match so badly and he's had
to try this this is actually maybe okay
though yeah he's got a lot of pawns his
paws are big
three pawns the issue being that this
b-pawn isn't really an extra pawn
because the a4 pawn stops two of them
well
but the e pawns coming strong yeah yeah
too fast
so he's going to get another win nice
one excuse me yeah king he's 70 67 i
think it's
sure can he 75 he's 60 67 just push him
yeah
so knee how's rating is dropping again
he's embarrassing himself with that
rating
yeah i don't i don't think we can invite
him any more tournaments right no he's
too low he's not over 3 300 anymore
and again he's probably going to do the
gameplay where he he uh
takes his time and losing it it makes
sense um from sports point of view
six minutes left
and
i'm pretty sure hike can finish this one
off
he definitely can yeah you know stamina
would just be absolutely tragic at this
point
it'd be quite funny but it'd be tragic
okay there we go
okay but um so nice to see him win a
couple of games i think adoption would
have been very unfair to such a great
player as as hike and okay i like this
he's changed his opening back to
back to this bit more exciting
semi-slave i like c can you castle queen
side no he's playing this position
online i want to see that more
fun castle and queen side this was the
first game wasn't it i was about to say
we started the match like this he's not
going to deviate now
and here comes the knight to e4 and
exactly what we're talking about i think
everybody remembers what we were talking
about in game one
of course everyone's got amazing
memories
you put the knight on e4 and even then
the bishop on b7 it got has more space
than it did with the pawn d5 but
that's the best it can do is going to d5
and getting traded off
yeah
so
four minutes left and
nihon a bit of a drink of his drink
there
and
wondering how many more games we can get
in it's probably gonna be a couple more
after this many the endings are quite
similar aren't they this is even similar
to the last game this pawn structure
they're getting it's like a french
defense kind of pawn structure
where
where generally the black pawns are a
little bit weaker because the d5 but
black has the space advantage which
certainly uh
validates it maybe white can go queen b5
now something like this he has done and
we just saw
hike do this from the white side where
he tried to infiltrate with his knight
here it comes so similar idea can the
knight just go in and win these pawns
very similar well f5 saying so that
schemes a tempo now knight c8 then
knight a7 it's amazing how it's the same
is that that's like okay exactly the
same right
bizarre
yeah and that that was an important
sequence and nihal now is up upon versus
being down the pawn in the previous game
but super similar
how do you wonder
um
don't ask me questions like that this
time
that's far too far too hard to work that
one out um i don't know i mean somehow
just play some moves
yeah i agree with simon just play some
moves and then the win will be there but
maybe you bring your king to b5 or
something like this i don't know try and
that's what he's trying to do
yeah uh the point we're getting at is
that this d4 pawn is the extra pawn but
it can't really move anywhere since the
knight on f6 covers the square if i
could draw my errors correctly and if
you ever played d5 my king just come to
c5 and i'm going to win that pawn at the
very least white can't push from there
yeah it's certainly not easy
to convert this one
yeah this looks
honestly just like it might be a draw
whoa well that's that's that's an
interesting way to
draw basically i mean you you assume the
king of portland is winning but there's
no way the white king can enter into the
position here
certainly cannot not from anywhere um is
he going to take on e4 and just gamble a
bit no okay
yeah this is a funny one you don't see
this very often
that draw
the white king can't get in anywhere
it's quite funny there uh black offered
a draw okay now they got it by
repetition so
so two minutes 24 left this could be the
last game most likely there's going to
be two more and uh we know who the
winner is going to be niihau i think
we're going to try to get an interview
afterwards in i believe so it'd be
excellent to hear the thoughts of the
players
um
if it is both players or just knee how
i'm not not sure of but
um i you know i want to i want to hear
what nihal's magic is of improving so
much
what is his magic formula yeah he just
was a very different player out of the
gates than he was against smirnoff
smirnov really came out swinging was up
several points in the longest time
patrol but today nihal was the one who
jumped out to the early lead he lost
that lead but he still was much better
at the start
yeah
and this is much better for a hike by
the way with the bishop pair in
particular is bishop on b2 oh
oh little little cheeky tactic
yeah stall upon and
should get the uh
well what's
tactical sequence where rooks are being
captured from minor pieces
i i've just lost the lost lost track
here i think white's doing well
i'm going to stay there yeah white's
obviously doing well here the bishop on
beaters robert pointed out is is a
winner andrew and your material up let's
see have a pawn so the opposite colored
bishops could give black better chances
in the end game but we're so far away
from an end game and with the weak king
and unopposed bishop and queen now on
the diagonal yeah certainly white scheme
to win it's probably going to be the
last game because there's only 45
seconds left now
um so we're assuming this is the last
game brilliant display today by nihal
um absolutely absolutely played
phenomenally well i mean
neither side has really blundered that
much no serious blunders and that just
shows the quality
of you know i mean obviously heights
gonna be disappointed but his play
wasn't terrible by any means it was just
knee how was phenomenal today absolutely
phenomenal yeah hike uh played very well
in spurts but ultimately you know nihal
just played better and the bullet didn't
help hike in the slightest because neil
is such a monster and here i think he's
just wasting the match clock the time is
officially over so this game is our last
and rook c7 just to defend against the
mate smart move
yes
watch out for 92 he moves king out the
way
and he's going to take on g4 oh rook c2
oh my gosh
nothing for hike today is working when
it rains it pause right
oh yeah
and it's pouring
there's only one check on each it can
come to g6 safely
okay
that's a bit annoying but you can move
the queen away he does
simply move the queen
yeah queen d6 oh
[Music]
i mean he just really wants to he just
wants he's showing off with his magical
moves now what a move to play in splits
i mean split second
split right there gosh because the queen
takes would have led to a checkmate in
the back and he's gonna repeat once and
is he gonna is he just gonna take the
draw who knows oh my gosh you still
can't take rookie one check queen enough
for his mate lovely lovely way to finish
the game so sharp
he showed positional plays today he
showed tactical ability and he showed
fighting spirit i mean phenomenal stuff
well we are
going to take a
quick break just to get the players on
the call so we can interview them uh
this was a great match victory from
nihal saarin we'll hear his thoughts in
just a few don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
[Music]
so
and we are joined by a finalist in the
junior speeches championship nihal huge
congratulations on an epic win uh my
first question for you is what was
different about the longest time control
because against anton smirnov you were a
bit sluggish at the start but today you
came out firing with two victories in
the first two games
uh yeah today i played a bit better i
think in general and
yeah the five minute portion was a bit
sloppy but then
but then i managed to play better yeah
it seemed like your your quality of your
chest i was very impressed with i mean
uh
last time i i sort of saw you play was
maybe
two three years ago and it seems like
you've got you've jumped a lot more
you've progressed a lot what's your
secret in the last couple of years hard
work or uh or can you give us any
secrets
yeah i think
yeah thank you for that i think i just
think i just improved my openings
and okay i i got to play a lot of strong
players on chess.com
ah so chess.com
yeah i play a lot here okay well that's
good to hear i mean you know now your
bullet rating is i mean through the roof
and you start out with the bullet with
like five straight victories is that
something that you work on like do you
put a lot of energy into that or would
you just say that
yeah you're young and it comes pretty
easily to you
yeah i think i i just like bullets the
most and
yeah
i just like bullet demos
i think that's my strongest point
you were so quick today there was many
moments when you just had for under five
seconds left and you kept finding very
good moves very good resources and uh i
thought it was very impressive the way
the way you want because obviously hike
is is a very good player and um you kind
of dominated
especially in the bullet section so
again congratulations there
yeah thank you i don't think he was in
his best shape for sure
yeah but i've played much better for
sure yeah
well i have a question we don't know who
your next opponent will be but it's
either going to be jeffrey zhang or
alexis saranac do you have i'm sure
you've played both many times but
is there somebody you'd rather face or
both are just you know worthy
competitors for you
yeah both are definitely worthy
yeah i don't know it's a really tough
choice i think
i don't really have a choice because
to jeffree star
yeah i was going to ask you so what your
experience is like against those two i
mean you know do you have you played one
of them more than the other
oh yeah i played quite a bit in sauna
like i played in
i played him in cap dutch last year and
also leon masters this year
and
yeah i lost two matches against him
so you want your revenge
yeah
time for revenge yeah you have to check
his openings out and prepare properly
it must be nice to be in the final
though it feels good yeah
yeah
well you know nihal i know it's uh
getting late by you i also have to go to
another show it doesn't uh my dad does
not stop right now but we want to extend
a huge congratulations you were very
impressive today you had so many people
rooting for you and i know that you're
making many people proud so your success
as simon noted is very uh you know
awesome to see
all right thank you
well done good luck in the fight as well
anyhow
thank you
okay bye
and that was niall saarin after
extremely impressive victory over the
very strong height marti rossian
he moves on to the jscc final where he
is a chance to not only win the
tournament but qualify for the speed
chess championship up next on the
twitch.tv chess channel is the
speedchest super swiss commentated by
one grandmaster maurice ashley and two
you know a guy you may be familiar with
i'll be doing the commentary for that as
well so simon it's been an absolute
pleasure do you have any kind of final
thoughts about the match we just saw and
maybe going forward in the jfcc
well it's been it's been a very exciting
match i mean i think nihal just showed
some amazing ability there extremely
impressive i mean
before the match i thought it'd be very
close obviously hike wasn't at his best
standard today but that's not taking any
weight anything away from me how and
he's going to be he's going to be really
tough to to defeat in the final um i
would like to say it's been a pleasure
obviously working with you robert and
a bit of a pleasure working with bick
it's a massive pleasure uh thank you to
everyone else who's been obviously
tuning in to the chat everywhere and
robert you've got a busy day today so
good good luck for the next event
uh thank you so much simon i mean it's
been i guess a couple years since we
commentated together but i hope it's
much sooner than that the next time
because it really was a blast for me and
of course our audience makes it that
much better the viewers who you know are
just bring such positivity and such a
love for the game of chess we appreciate
that so everybody stay safe uh enjoy
more chess just go over the you're
getting rated so you're gonna go over
there right now but there's more chess
to be had with some superstar players
for the speed chest super swiss for now
i'm gonna sign off eat the quickest of
quick lunches and then commentate some
more so see you soon everybody
[Music]
you